[Music]
thank you
[Music]
my good Doctor Walker Matthew
Tim it is a splendid Delight to be with
you thanks very much for having me
absolutely and this is for people
listening a very self-interested
conversation
you and I connected I think
not that long ago maybe six months ago
or so after I finished why we sleep
which is a spectacular book it has as
many highlights I think as words in the
book in my Kindle notes and
not only did it change how I think about
sleep but it both gave me answers to
outstanding questions because I've
battled with onset insomnia my entire
life or for as long as I can remember
certainly it gave me better questions
and it gave me better Frameworks for
thinking about sleep and this
conversation
for folks who are wondering what the
road map might look like is intended to
explore areas of personal interest to me
and also several or many areas that I
don't think you have explored in in
depth in other places so we're we're
intending to check both of those boxes
and I thought we would start if we can
just you know Skip the
foreplay and jump right into the the
main event here
discuss the connection or connections
the interrelatedness between sleep and
Alzheimer's disease I wanted to just hop
right into it I have Alzheimer's disease
on both sides of my family and have seen
this
up close and personal
what are the connections if any between
those two
yeah I think this is perhaps one of the
most exciting areas to have emerged in
sleep science over the past maybe five
or six years or so and I'm just taking a
step back of course everyone knows that
Alzheimer's disease it's a form of
dementia typified by memory impairment
and memory Decline and we've learned
that there are at least two protein
pathological culprits that contribute to
Alzheimer's disease one of those is
called beta amyloid which is a sticky
toxic protein that builds up in the
brain and the second is called Tau
protein so coming back to your question
how are those things related to sleep
well it's probably unfolded gosh maybe
in a three part or even four part story
and I'm very nervous to say four part
and you'll see why in terms of that in
just a second but the three main parts
were correlation
causation and then mechanism
and so
early on what we started to discover is
that individuals who reported sleeping
six hours or less across their lifespan
had a significantly higher risk of
developing high amounts of this toxic
beta amyloid and also Tau protein in the
brain then we discovered that two Sleep
Disorders both insomnia and sleep apnea
which is a condition of sort of heavy
snoring sometimes you stop breathing
it's clinically diagnosed both of those
conditions were associated with a higher
risk of both Alzheimer's pathology but
also the transition to early stages and
ultimately the transition to full-blown
Alzheimer's disease
in fact I think there was a recent
meta-analysis looking at maybe it was
over 27 different studies and what they
found is that people who had sleep
problems during the lifespan were about
3.78 times more likely to develop the
early stages of Alzheimer's disease in a
premature fashion
so those were these epidemiological
studies those are simply correlational
they're associational they don't prove
you know causality
so correlation then went in search of
causation
and what we've discovered we and other
individuals some people working in
animal cities we work in humans
but across species what we found is that
if you just Prive individuals of a night
of sleep or even if you deprive them
selectively of just their deep non-rem
sleep across a single night then the
next day we can see an immediate and
significant increase in beta amyloid and
Tau protein circulating in the
bloodstream circulating in what we call
the cerebral spinal fluid of the brain
which is this a fluid that bathes the
brain and also using special pet
scanning images we've been able to see
that same buildup of amyloid within the
brain itself
and in fact there was a recent study
that looked at this these signals of
metabolic
sort of detritus in the brain and what
they found is that after one night of
sleep deprivation even a full recovery
night of sleep was not sufficient to
downgrade those metabolic toxins that
have been building up in the brain
so
so in that sense it was a demonstration
causally that you can remove this thing
called sleep or even selectively excise
different types of sleep and you can
manipulate the amount of Alzheimer's
protein in the brain the next day
so that was the causal evidence
causation then wanted sort of you know a
mechanism and
perhaps here in some ways you can
reverse engineer it or you can flip it
on its head if that's the bad that
happens if I take sleep away from you
then what is it about sleep when we get
it that de-escalates your Alzheimer's
disease pathology risk and this comes on
to a series of discoveries the principal
person underlying this was a wonderful
scientist at the University of Rochester
called Macon nedergaard and she was
working in mice and she made three
stunning discoveries in my mind at least
the first is that she discovered that
the brain has a cleansing system
now it sounds strange you know many
people would think well it must have
because the body has a cleansing system
and everyone's familiar with it it's
called the lymphatic system but we
didn't think that the brain had its own
cleansing system she discovered it and
it's called the glymphatic system
and it's it's named by the way that way
because of the cells that make it up
these they're called glial cells they're
a different form of brain cell we've got
neurons and we've got glial cells and
it's the glial cells that make up this
network of this cleansing system so that
was the first discovery that she made
if that wasn't amazing enough she then
found two more related discoveries what
she then found was that that cleansing
mechanism in the brain is not always
switched on in high flow volume across
the 24-hour period of course the 24-hour
clock face instead it was particularly
when those mice fell asleep and when
they went into deep non-rapid eye
movement sleep or non-rem sleep
um the other stage of sleep being rap
and I moved and sleep but it was during
deep non-rem sleep when that pulsing
cleansing system kicked into high gear
and so
that was then her sort of shift to then
say well what are those things that the
brain is cleansing during deep sleep and
this is what brings us on to or back to
Alzheimer's disease two of the pieces of
the metabolic byproducts that were being
washed away by deep non-rem sleep at
night were beta amyloid and Tau protein
these two culprits associated with
Alzheimer's disease and scientists in
Boston a couple of years ago and we've
now replicated this in humans as well
identified a similar cleansing mechanism
in humans using special MRI scans
so that was evidence almost from a
biochemical perspective and this is
probably slightly hyperbolic to say a
mindful of it but biochemically perhaps
it's true which is
we were starting to understand that
wakefulness was low-level brain damage
and sleep was your sanitary salvation
it was almost like a good night's sleep
clean that was a power cleanse for the
brain that was happening during sleep
but this started to explain why you got
maybe this trajectory of Alzheimer's
disease it went all the way back to the
associational studies so now we can
understand why night after night if
you're not getting the sleep that you
need you're not cleansing the brain of
the pathology and it's it's not vast
that builds up after one night of sleep
and I don't want to scare anyone here
and I've you know I'm sure I'll probably
get some
concerned voices I'm not trying to make
anyone nervous about a bad night of
sleep and the next day you've guaranteed
your Alzheimer's disease fate that's not
at all the situation but it did help us
understand that night after night if
you're not cleansing the brain it
becomes like compounding interest on a
loan that it continues to escalate time
and time again night after night
and then if that wasn't depressing
enough we then went on to make a further
discovery that it's a vicious cycle
that Alzheimer's disease pathology those
proteins do not build up in the brain
homogeneously they don't build up in all
areas of the brain equally
and what we discovered is that the parts
of the brain that start to get attacked
by Alzheimer's disease early on are
unfortunately the same regions of the
brain that generate deep non-rem sleep
the same stage of sleep that's
associated with the cleansing isn't it
just and so now we'd found this vicious
spiral that if you don't get enough
sleep each night you get more of that
Alzheimer's build up the more that
builds up the less the brain is capable
of generating deep sleep the less deep
sleep the more that builds up what are
the structures involved with the
production of that deep non-rem sleep
it's essentially a network of brain
regions constellation exactly but one of
if you look at it with brain scans or
electrical recordings one of the main
epicenters in fact probably the
principal epicenter that generates this
deep sleep is a part of the frontal lobe
particularly the middle part of your
frontal lobe so if you sort of put your
finger just above your nose and slide it
up about an inch and a half that's the
middle part of what we call the
prefrontal cortex or the medial
prefrontal cortex that is a deep sleep
generating center for the brain you get
principle dominance of your deep sleep
in that part of the brain and then these
big brain waves they Splash on the brain
and they actually wave across the brain
from the front of the brain to the back
from the front to the back it's this
beautiful mechanism that we can see this
this sort of wave of these deep slow
brain waves it's amazing and so that was
a part of the brain that showed these
Alzheimer's attacks early on and it's
the same region that is generating the
deep sleep in adults so that was the
demonstration of mechanism that helped
us perhaps go back and explain the
associations then
perhaps the the fourth ingredient that
I'm really
you know I'm almost nervous to say it
because it's the most dangerous of all
things which is the suggestion of Hope
and I don't mean to make false sort of
promises here but what I find
interesting is that unlike many of the
other features that we know are
associated with Alzheimer's disease
for example changes in the physical
structure of the brain or even the blood
flow dynamics of the brain those are
very difficult to treat right now and
Medicine doesn't have any good wholesale
approaches but if sleep is a missing
piece in the explanatory puzzle of aging
and Alzheimer's disease then maybe we
can do something about it sleep is a
modifiable factor
and we've been looking at this in the
laboratory we've been approaching this
not by using sleeping pills and we may
come on to those things they seem to be
more blunt to instruments that don't
produce necessarily naturalistic sleep
but we've been developing some
technology it's called direct current
brain stimulation which which sounds
like the stuff of Science Fiction it's
actually science fact where you apply
these Patsy head and you insert a small
amount of voltage into the brain and
it's so small by the way that you
typically don't feel it but it has a
measurable impact
and early studies demonstrated that if
you apply this stimulation during sleep
as if you're sort of singing in time
with those deep sleep rain waves not
only can you amplify the size of those
deep sleep brain waves but in doing so
people were able to almost double the
amount of memory benefit that you get
from sleep
so so the question then was could we
translate that same affordable
potentially portable technology into
older adults and could we restore back
some deep sleep and sort of Salvage
aspects of learning and memory function
that's that's one of our goals and we've
I've been developing this and have a
startup company that's public now that's
looking at this to me though that is
probably not really where I'll
ultimately be excited about because
thinking about late stage Alzheimer's
disease when the brain has been
pathologized that much it's very
difficult to salvage
I am much more interested in shifting
from a model in Alzheimer's of late
stage treatment to mid-life prevention
because to me if I look at the Sleep
data that's when you start to see the
Great Depression of your deep sleep it's
bloody depressing I know I'm an
incredibly depressing person but if you
look it's in your mid to late 30s that
we start to see the decline in deep
sleep
so could I intervene in midlife and
start sort of pushing back against the
decline of deep sleep and in doing so
could we bend the arrow of Alzheimer's
disease risk down on itself
so that's so sort of shifting from a
model of late stage sikka to a model of
mid-life health care I think that's
probably a much more reasonable approach
Matt what causes the decline in
deep sleep whether it's absolute hours
or just percentage of sleep when people
get into their
mid-30s let's just say how is that
explained currently
you can already start to see the brain
atrophy beginning okay so it's just
overall brain atrophy yeah there is a
development and there are some sort of
sex differences it turns out
unfortunately that men seem to decline
in that deep sleep earlier than women
women will hang in there females will
hang in there for the deep sleep a
little bit longer than men but
ultimately by late stage there's a more
severe sort of decrease later in life in
females so net net they ultimately get
there so but it's simply because we
start to just like the rest of us I'm
sure many people once you get into your
mid to sort of late 30s you start to
think wow I'm just not as robust as I
used to be I start to get more injuries
you know the body starts to deteriorate
it's very generous way to put it robust
I'm not as robust as I used to be well
I'm so sensitive now because you know I
am I I think I'm about the same age as
you you know I'm I'm now in the solidly
in the foothills of middle age so I want
to be tender and sensitive to myself and
be politically correct
you know what I'll take the tender to
yourself with the politically correct we
can skip but yeah I think it's political
correctness the language of cowards in
truth so you're right all right let's be
so we can be the countervailing force
but before we get to that gender
differences and and I apologize in
advance I'm going to ask a lot of
questions in the in the line of
three-year-olds and four-year-olds I'm
going to ask why and why and why a lot
in part because I find it so
simultaneously
exciting and depressing more so exciting
that we spend let's call it and I'm not
using a precise number here but a third
of Our Lives of sleep and we relative to
so many other areas knows so little
about it it's just incredible and I find
it so full of Promise as a result
meaning
it could represent one of the most
powerful levers that we can pull for
different purposes but coming back to
the age-related decline why do women
hang in there longer is that due to
estrogen a lower level of other hormones
other factors
do you have any any explanation for why
they seem to hang in longer than men
it's a great question largely unclear at
this stage that some of it may again
come down to brain atrophy that the
speed of that atrophy in the brain in
those sleep generating regions is more
rapid and more accelerated in men than
it is in women
other aspects you're absolutely right
maybe the sex hormones that we think
that
aspects of estrogen luteinizing hormone
may be more either sleep protective or
neuroprotective it's a little bit
unclear right now
certainly menopause of course is a huge
issue and once that begins we know that
the Sleep issues are markedly higher in
women than they are in men as well
so right now the evidence there is is
far less clear
and to come to your point you're
absolutely right in terms of sleep and
you know we know so much about our
waking lives but we seem to know so
little about our sleeping lives there's
definitely been
a remarkable amount of evidence so much
so that perhaps a dimwit like me can
write try and write a book that's 130
000 words of of facts but you know
you're absolutely right if you think
about it 20 30 40 years ago we used to
ask what are the functions of sleep and
back then the crass answer was that we
sleep to cure sleepiness which is you
know just a ridiculous equivalent of
saying well I eat to cure hunger that
tells you nothing about the biological
nutritional benefits of food and the
same was was true for sleep in in a way
though now 20 or 30 years later we've
had to upend that question based on the
weight of the evidence now we have to
ask is there any major physiological
system within your body or any major
operational network of your brain that
isn't wonderfully enhanced by sleep when
you get it or demonstrably impaired when
you don't get enough
and so far the answer largely seems to
be no are there any species in any I'm
gonna get way outside of my
my area of expertise here
phylum kingdom are there any species
that you're aware of of anything that do
not require sleep and maybe that's a
poorly worded question but is there no
it's a great question anything notable
that does not require
sleep yeah how far down can we go down
to the level of bacterium I mean how how
small can we go and still see a near
ubiquitous need for something resembling
sleep
you know some people have said that
nothing in biology makes sense unless
you look at it through the lens of
evolution and we have certainly done
that in the Sleep field
I think it's fairly safe to say that at
least in every species that's been
carefully studied to date sleep or
something that looks very much like it
seems to be present
and so what that means is that sleep
perhaps emerged with life itself on it
on the planet and has fought its way
through heroically every step along the
evolutionary path
which if that's the case it must mean
that sleep is absolutely fundamentally
necessary across phylogeny that perhaps
is one common theme and function of
sleep
how far back in our time capsule can we
go through evolution
certainly we see it there in all
mammalian species than if we descend
down if we look at birds reptiles and
fish we can see sleep we also see both
types of sleep in mammals and in Birds
we don't actually see REM sleep or dream
sleep in most reptiles
and there is some evidence that it's an
emerging sort of controversy is to have
perhaps there's like a Proto version of
dream sleep that comes out with just REM
sleep you can think of it as in reptiles
but we don't see it there can we go
further back yes we can see insects even
sleep so fruit flies will will sleep
go back even further and you can find
that earthworms which are ancient in
terms of their evolutionary history even
earthworms will have a period that looks
very much like sleep it's called
lethargicus and they just become
immobile literally looks like these
worms sort of you know go into this
state and cellular state in fact not
just a a motility state but a cellular
state of of sleep and then some people
have even suggested that for some forms
of bacteria as long as they live several
days some bacteria don't live longer
than 24 hours so you can't really ask
this question but if they live for
several days they will go through cycles
of
activity and inactivity from a cellular
perspective which is perhaps the the
predecessor the precursor of these
things that we call wake and sleep
States
you can even do a nerdout and I've I
kind of put this out I'm thinking I'm
desperately wrong on this one too but
most of us assume that sleep evolved
but why should we make that assumption
why isn't it that sleep was the default
State when life emerged and it was
wakefulness that evolved
that it was from the Sleep state that
wakefulness emerged that we came out and
we started to develop wakefulness that's
you know it's almost this assumption
that sleep evolved and there was
wakefulness before it rather than the
other way around now I don't think we'll
necessarily ever be able to prove that
but it's an interesting kind of Duncan
to to play with I love that do you say
good Duncan is that what you just said
yeah like a a brain experiment like it's
just a wow oh I see what you did there
that you pulled out some German that's
what it was
Duncan I'm bilingual you know I can
speak both British in a little bit of
American that's it what I heard was good
Duncan like a good day from Australia
but like G apostrophe and then Duncan
like Dunkin Donuts but yes I I hear you
sorry and I should I should also say I
think lethargic is my Gladiator name but
I'll put that to one side it may
actually have to be like a license plate
on because our mutual friend and Peter
attia we we'd love to race cars but
based on my lap times I think I need
lethargic I should guess like I have
clearly nowhere near as good as he is
well all the mtor license plates are
taken so you'll have to you'll have to
make do with lethargicus let's revisit
this direct current brain stimulation
for the amplification let's say
extension of of deep sleep
could you describe
in practice what this looks like over
the course of an evening you could also
mention the company name because I know
people will be interested and compare
this to
TMS might be
too much of a layup in terms of
comparison but let's just say tdcs so
other types of transcranial
or brain stimulation that can be used
for other purposes which could relate to
different types of therapy and treatment
of depression could relate to the
enhancement of memory in some cases yeah
but I would love to learn more of the
direct current brain stimulation and
what that looks like in practice
so the complex version of it requires
you to be in the Sleep laboratory or at
least for us to be recording the
electrical brain waves
of your natural sleep and then
essentially what we start to do is we'll
develop an algorithm that understands
the cycling Cadence of your deep slow
brain waves and then start to temporally
predict where the next brain wave will
hit in its sort of monumental peak of
explosion and then you time the
stimulation this is almost at the
millisecond level to strike at the the
point of midnight as it were on that big
powerful slow wave and therefore it's
almost like acting as a choir to a
flagging lead vocalist that these deep
sleep brain waves hundreds of thousands
of cells in your cortex what they're
doing to create these deep sleep brain
waves by the way they all fire together
and then they all go silent together and
they all fire together and go science
and what we're trying to do is estimate
the point the next wave when they're all
going to fire together and then we
stimulate to activate and sort of
amplify that stimulation even more so it
requires this closed-loop feedback where
you're measuring the brain and you're
stimulating then you keep measuring and
then you stimulate and people are
wearing Caps or what is the the format
the sort of physical format it's
different sometimes we're just placing
electrodes on the head and then the
stimulation pads are going in between
those electrodes and you can have a very
simple number of a very stripped down
number of those alleged and this is what
makes it now you appointed for people
who are not watching you pointed
basically to that medial prefrontal area
if I'm not mistaken When you mention
that's right the stimulation pads so
those are effectively being placed over
that cortical area that's right yeah no
they're placed over that cortical area
and this is why you know I can speak
about the simulation and it sounds
fairly simplistic It's actually an
incredibly complex
high-dimensionality problem what I mean
by that is you can ask well firstly
where do you put the pads to try to
create this stimulation whereabouts on
the frontal lobe or do you put another
one somewhere at the back of the brain
so your extinct current from the front
to the back how do you do that the next
question is how long do you stimulate
for right to create this profile the
next component is what frequency do you
stimulate so coming back to the more
complex version of this you're measuring
the brain waves and then you're
stimulating in this predictive manner as
I said that's stroke of midnight what
we're now starting to try and do
is a very different approach with the
stimulation company I think it's
unlikely that people are going to start
strapping things on their head and
wishing to go to bed and this is the
reason that I'm not necessarily the
biggest fan of sort of sleep trackers
where you stick them on your head or
even wrist watches Etc chest straps
because we take things off to go to
sleep we don't put things on and so the
shift that we made with the technology
that we've been developing with the
company is what is the name of the
company
the company's name is STEM Science and
we're just in the early stages here and
I think you know I I am very happy to
take a long time to develop something
that is scientifically proven I don't
want to sell snake oil out there if it's
a device you know if my mother for
example who's in her elderly age is told
that the stimulation device is going to
help her then I don't want that to be
scientific falsehood so we're taking our
time but the company is called STEM
Science and people can have a look at it
what we're trying to do though is
something slightly different
we're trying to
stimulate before sleep for about five to
ten minutes and this is a slightly
different approach it's a little a good
analogy would be a child on a swing
where you know to begin with you have to
start pushing the child on the swing and
at some point they gain enough momentum
that you can stop pushing and they keep
oscillating back and forth so now we've
taken this approach where we're
stimulating sort of you know as you're
cleaning your teeth you stick the
headband on you get the stimulation and
you're essentially fertilizing and
stimulating that territory of the brain
to then germinate more deep sleep
naturalistically when you fall asleep
and what's nice about it is
when you do this stimulation for that
duration of time it has a sort of an
efficacious a dose
impact for about two to three hours
afterwards so you can stimulate and you
can take it off and it has this
lingering effect as it were
and what's nice about that is that's the
time when we have most of our deep
non-rem sleep deep non-rem sleep does
not keep coming cycle after cycle 90
site minute cycle after 90 minute cycle
across the night you get most of your
deep sleep in the first half of the
night most of it in the first two hours
of the night so we can nicely sort of
fertilize that territory of the first
couple of hours of Deep Sleep using the
pre-sleep stimulation and therefore you
can remove the components of having to
measure the brain waves and do all of
this fancy acrobatic technology
but coming back to your question I keep
digressing but actually let me pause for
one second so just I know I'm subverting
my own question here but
a few things the first is if if we're
looking at the option of pushing the
swing set so to speak while people are
brushing their teeth and so on so
they're having that
amplification for
10 15 minutes and then they go to sleep
what types of clinical outcomes or
measurable outcomes would you hope to
observe not asking you to
paint a picture of something that's pie
in the sky but yeah just speculating a
bit with the information that you have
what would you hope to observe in terms
of changes
we're actually measuring these outcomes
so we're doing a whole bunch of Trials
of validity trials within the company
essentially scientific studies so we
have outcome measures along the
following lines the first is the speed
with which you fall asleep and it's
something that we call Sleep onset
latency my nemesis
yeah and that's a component of what we
call wonderful insomnia my good friends
sleep onset so well it is and that's a
form of what we call onset insomnia or
sleep onset [ __ ] out of luck in my case
with insomnia across the lifespan it is
no fun at all so one of the things that
we're trying to do is to see will that
that pulsing I'm we're pulsing still at
the slow brainwave frequency I should
note can we increase the drowsiness
pre-sleep so that sleep arrives with you
with greater alacrity as it were and you
reduce the Sleep onset latency as it
were that's the first thing the second
is that we then in our scientific
studies are measuring sleep electrically
and we're looking to see if the amount
of deep sleep or the number of those
deep sleep brain waves has increased
during sleep that's another outcome
measure
a third outcome measure is the number of
Awakenings that happen during the night
so one form of sleep difficulties and
insomnia is difficulty falling asleep
which is as you have described publicly
before something that has been a
challenge for you the other component
there is something called Sleep
maintenance insomnia which is I can fall
asleep fine but then I wake up and I
can't fall back asleep so that's
something else that we're trying to
Target just because of the clinical
efficacy the third component involves
another actual flavor of insomnia which
is not just I have problems falling
asleep or I have problems staying asleep
but you can also get a diagnosis of
insomnia if the next day you say well I
fell asleep fine and I stayed asleep but
I don't feel refreshed I don't feel
restored rejuvenated by my sleep that's
a different form of insomnia and they're
not mutually exclusive those three
things unfortunate you can have all of
them
and that's another outcome measure that
we're looking at when you wake up the
next morning
and you subjectively ask people how
refreshed and restored by your sleep do
you feel is that better as a consequence
of nights when you've had stimulation
versus nights when you haven't
so those are some of the outcome
measures that we're interested in
if we see some of those outcome measures
then we're looking at function not just
did you sleep better the night before
and do you wake up feeling more
refreshed but then the next day
presumably because sleep is interwoven
with so many incredible brain and body
benefits other outcomes are you better
able to learn and remember the next day
because of that better sleep is your
mood improved is your metabolic
regulation of your blood sugar better
and do you not crave food as much
because your appetite hormones are
controlled or your blood pressure is
altered those are the kind of that's my
dream set of things much later down the
pipeline
all right so I have a million follow-up
questions as you might imagine and what
I'd like to do is return to
the concern and fear that people have
related to neurodegenerative disease
specifically Alzheimer's and I'm going
to talk for a second so I've I apologize
in advance
first I'm going to double down on my
apology and say I did not mean to imply
that the state of sleep research is
dismal by my previous comment only that
all of those sense of millionaires and
billionaires who are spending their time
trying to figure out how to live to 140
should take a substantial amount of
their funds for research and allocate it
to sleep related research in my opinion
if they're looking at optimizing not
just life span but Health span
so I'll put a button in that then we
were talking about the direct current
brain stimulation but an outstanding
question for many people listening to
this might be
along the following lines
I agree I Now understand how important
this deep sleep is for the let's just
call it
brain
maintenance recovery
Etc vis-a-vis the lymphatic system and
perhaps other Pathways how do I increase
my deep sleep if I do not have access
which no one presumably does to direct
current brain stimulation along lines
that you're describing what are some
other things that people can do and
I'd like to pause here just to maybe
front load a bit for folks of personal
contacts if that's okay with you
and and so I'll mention a few things the
first of which being a disclaimer that
nothing we're discussing in this podcast
is intended to be medical advice it is
for informational purposes only please
consult your licensed Health Care
Professionals before taking or ceasing
anything especially prescription drugs
and I mentioned that in part because
we'll be talking about some of these
compounds so I have had
onset insomnia
for
as long as I can remember and I have
theories for why that that that may be
the case
some of them relating to premature birth
and being in the NICU for a very very
long time but who knows ultimately what
the causes are but but symptomatically
I often throughout my life have required
or seemingly required one to three to
four hours to fall asleep and that has
had I think far reaching consequences
including or at least contributing to
depressive episodes and other types of
cognitive challenges short-term memory
being the most obvious I think
and a number of things I'd say in the
last year have been very helpful and I I
owe you thanks for
taking the time to have several
conversations with me and of course in
conjunction with my conversations with
doctors and people like Peter Tia and so
on have led me to experiment with a
number of things that I found very
helpful there are the environmental
factors and those are worth talking
about and the behavioral factors
avoiding screens past a certain point
Etc but
I will just mention a few things that
have been very helpful Trazodone
particularly for decreasing that
the Sol
yeah and increasing the speed to sleep
pregabalin which we might talk about
just a little bit to explain what that
is due to lower back pain and some
muscular issues that have been
contributing to
several species of sleep problems
thirdly and these are not taken at the
same time typically in my case but
some type of THC and CBD combination and
for me THC
is a necessary appears to be a necessary
component if that is absent CBD at least
at the dosages that I have most
frequently experimented with does not
seem to address any of these primary
issues but I will say in the last six
months paying attention to temperature
consistent timing caffeine intake
both quantity and schedule
actually had a pretty good run of good
sleep so I want to thank you for the
book and then also the the input that
you've provided over time so folks who
are listening to this podcast we will
talk about a number of the things that I
just mentioned it's not all going to be
technology that is in the in the lab and
unavailable so How might people think
about increasing let's say they have a
family history of Alzheimer's and they
want to get on the maintenance train
they want to
do as much
possible to ensure that their lymphatic
system and so on is is operating in top
order
great question and in some ways you can
break it down I'm almost not going to do
a pull-up piece or a tear and think
about it as like a two by two but I
won't go without it but I'm gonna go
full McKenzie on us yeah I know yeah
well maybe I can one up him and do like
a two by three but
you can think about things that you
should not do that otherwise would be
roadblocks to deep sleep and things that
you should do more of that will
facilitate an increase amount of deep
sleep at least that's one of the ways
the frame works with which I think about
it so you've already mentioned some of
the things to be mindful of that will
decrease the amount of Deep Sleep the
first of those being
unfortunately caffeine caffeine and we
can we'll probably go into detail here
is certainly something that not only
disrupts your sleep and makes it harder
for you to fall asleep it does seem to
selectively deprive that deep sleep and
particularly the quality of those deep
sleep brain waves especially in the
first couple of hours of the night so
that's one thing to be mindful of
the second is probably
light exposure
light exposure in the evening in fact
there was a recent study published by
Phyllis Z from Northwestern
demonstrating that even light exposure
in the bedroom at night while you're
sleeping despite your eyelids being
closed can still penetrate and provide a
signal into the brain that will decrease
the amount of deep sleep so trying to
aim for Darkness not just in the last
couple of hours before bed but also
darkness when you're in bed blackout
curtains eye masks all of those good
things
feel free to do those things too so be
mindful of caffeine be mindful of also
light I think
the other big issue and it's really hard
to manage is Stress and Anxiety one of
the ways and we've been doing a lot of
work in sleep and mental health one of
the ways that you can decimate your deep
sleep is to increase your state of
anxiety and this has been demonstrated
in animal studies and we've demonstrated
it in humans too if you induce a state
of anxiety not only is sleep disrupted
but the type of sleep that is excised
most powerfully from your sort of finger
buffet menu of different stages of sleep
is deep sleep so that's another way that
there will be a prevention of deep sleep
coming on to the things that you can do
for yourself to enable more deep sleep
that are not necessarily technologically
advanced
one of the most interesting I find is is
temperature
that temperature makes a huge difference
to the amount of deep sleep and
temperature is not quite as simple as
keep it cold even though people like me
have probably been out there just saying
oh you know keep your bedroom colors the
best thing it's actually a three-part
equation that you need to warm up to
cool down to fall asleep and then you
need to stay cool to stay asleep and
then you need to warm up to wake up
but coming back to the first two parts
of that ingredient and why temperature
is important and what people can do
what we've discovered is that you need
to drop your core body temperature to
initiate sleep and in fact people with
insomnia interestingly have problems
with thermoregulation and they don't
seem to be able to thermoregulate as
well so you can do these studies where
you place people's hands or feet into a
hot bath and you can look at how well
the hands and their feet vasodilate
which is in other words the vessels open
up and that's how we release heat that's
how we regulate our body temperature but
insomnia patients don't seem to be able
to regulate their body temperature as
well they don't phasodilate as well what
this means is that for most people who
are healthy sleepers we can sort of the
way that we drop our core body
temperature is actually by having
pushing the blood out to the surface of
the skin and as we fall asleep if you
move the blood out to the hands and the
feet and the face which is particularly
where you get the highest amount of
vasculature sort of surface area
at that point you can emit the heat from
the core of the body and your core body
temperature plummets
the way that people can manipulate this
is by using hot baths or showers before
bed I think many people sometimes will
say well I know that if I have a hot
bath or a shower before bed
I get into bed and I typically fall
asleep faster
and you think that it's because you're
nice and warm and toasty it's the
opposite it's that the warm water on the
skin actually dilates the blood vessels
that's why I would get rosy cheeks and
all of a sudden the blood comes to the
surface and it's almost as though you're
charming like a snake charmer you're
charming the heat out of the core of the
body bringing it to the surface and when
you get out of the bath your core body
temperature actually plummets and that
is what helps you fall asleep and stay
asleep more soundly if we it's so
reliable by the way we call it the warm
bath effect in sleep science and that
will consistently increase the amount of
deep sleep that you get as well there's
also been some cities where you can warm
the hands and the feet right you don't
need to jump in the bath or the shower
you can use a hot water bottle for
example and we're thinking about a
low-five version of Technology rather
than a fancy headband as well we we
haven't yet got funding for these
studies but can you selectively just
warm you know parts of the bed or parts
of the feet and can you instigate sleep
and they did it actually in rats these
studies way back they started to warm
the pores of rats and bring the blood to
the surface of the pores and those Rats
start to fall asleep more quickly and
you can replicate that in humans now too
so that's another way that you can think
about doing it
other aspects that we know can increase
deep sleep exercise is a really good one
any particular types of exercise
there have been a series of reviews that
have looked at this and
it seems to be that when it comes to
Deep Sleep it may be that more aerobic
forms of exercise so basically sort of
more cardio based forms of exercise may
get you greater bang for your buck in
terms of Deep Sleep enhancement relative
to let's say just heavy resistance
training and lifting weights in the gym
of course that can also be aerobic
depending on sort of how intense you go
but also any form of exercise seems to
be beneficial for deep sleep but if you
want to then split it apart sort of
cardio versus lifting weights cardio
seems to give you a slightly greater
benefit
people have then tried to split down the
cardio you know running versus cycling
and at that point I think the analyzes
just get so fine-grained that you start
to lose some of the signal in the noise
but exercise is another great way that
you can enhance that deep sleep
there are not so many cities but there
are a few cities demonstrating that it
doesn't seem to be strongly time of day
dependent so
some people may then ask well when
should I be doing that exercise to best
optimize my deep sleep should I just be
doing it from seven to nine PM or from
you know 8 A.M to 10 A.M
we don't really see that much of a
difference there's a few studies that
can argue differences there but I
wouldn't worry about that then though
the overall message is that exercise
versus non-exercise exercise exercise
always wins out in terms of generating
that more and greater and more powerful
deep sleep
yeah I would say pick the schedule and
the type of exercise you're actually
going to [ __ ] do consistently would
probably beat the perfect prescription
it's like yeah okay you're gonna do wind
Sprints up that hill with bowling balls
taped your hands this the literature
shows that's ideal it's like well good
luck with adherence right so stick
exactly stick to what you're gonna do
yeah I want to come back to caffeine
so I'm looking at notes prep notes for
this conversation
you've changed your mind it seems on
coffee in so much as you now advocate
for it or at least support the idea of a
cup of coffee in the morning
and an outstanding question because we
were going back and forth on what we
should talk about in this conversation
that I really don't know the answer to
and that is why is coffee associated
with so many of the same health benefits
asleep it doesn't seem at least at face
value to to make immediate sense so so
both of those
why a cup of coffee in the morning
and why is it associated with some of
the benefits of sleep
and maybe you could also get into some
of the pharmacokinetics of of caffeine
or
I mean I guess coffee could be its own
thing just in terms of Half-Life and
stuff so people have an idea
yes so I've certainly changed my my tune
on caffeine and I think just try to
change my tune in general I think when I
first came out with the book and was
just getting my
training wheels underneath me in public
communication I think I was probably a
bit too
absolutist in truth than anyone who
speaks in absolute she should always be
weary of and I was very much guilty of
that and I think this that was true for
caffeine and sleep in general but let me
just come back to the first part of the
question which is caffeine what is it
how does it work in terms of waking you
up how does it work in terms of
preventing you from sleeping but also
why I despite those things I would still
advocate for it all right caffeine is a
chemical is I'm sure you and everyone
else knows it's a stimulants it's a
psychoactive stimulant one of one of the
few that we feel readily comfortable
giving our children but caffeine Works
in a very interesting way within the
brain which brings us back to another
chemical that sounds very similar called
adenosine caffeine adenosine
from the moment that you and I and
everyone listening I suppose woke up
this morning a chemical built up in your
brain and that chemical is called
adenosine and the more of it that builds
up the sleepier that you feel and so we
think of adenosine as a signal of sleep
pressure it's not a mechanical pressure
by the way it doesn't mean that the end
the end of the day your head is nearly
going to explode on the basis of your
adenosine it's just it's a chemical
pressure
caffeine Works to keep us awake by way
of competing with adenosine so the
longer that we're awake the more
adenosine is building up and that
adenosine is telling your brain okay
you're getting sleepier and sleepier and
after about 16 hours of being awake you
should feel
heavily weighed down by that adenosine
signal that you can fall asleep easily
and then you can stay asleep
caffeine works by way of racing into the
system and it latches on to those
adenosine receptors
but what it doesn't do is activate them
because you would think well if it's
binding on and latching onto those
welcome sites of adenosine in the brain
then wouldn't that make you more sleepy
well the reason it doesn't is because it
has the opposite effect well not quite
the opposite effect it races in and it
just latches itself onto those receptors
and inactivates those receptors so it
doesn't inhibit The receptors it just
blocks them and so it's almost as though
caffeine is like the mute button on your
remote TV controller it just comes in
and it mutes the signal of adenosine of
of sleepiness so it's what we call a
competitive receptor blocker and it has
very sharp elbows it will come in and it
will nudge adenosine out of the way
latch on and hijack those receptors and
block the signal of sleepiness and
that's why all of a sudden you think
well gosh I was feeling pretty sleepy
I've been awake for 14 hours I have an
espresso I don't feel sleepy anymore
it's not as though you've removed the
adenosine the adenosine is still present
sleepiness is still present and it will
continue to build up the longer that
you're awake it's simply that your brain
is no longer getting the message of
adenosine because caffeine is blocking
the signal if that makes some sense so
that's the reason that caffeine will
then
start to disrupt your sleep and it will
disrupt your sleep in probably several
different ways the first is that it will
because it's a stimulant prolong the
time it takes you to fall asleep and you
you mentioned that too the other aspect
of caffeine though is that it's what we
call anxiogenic that it increases your
anxiety
and anxiety including what we think of
as physiological anxiety biological
anxiety which is essentially having your
fight or flight branch of the nervous
system switched on into higher gear and
aspects of your stress chemistry and
things like
cortisol those things will be ramped up
by way of caffeine and that is the exact
opposite of what you need
to be able to fall asleep you need to
disengage the fight or flight branch of
the nervous system and shift over to the
more restful branch of the nervous
system that we call the parasympathetic
nervous system
and you can't do that because of the
caffeine and so what happens is that
psychologically the caffeine is
preventing you from falling asleep then
you start to get anxious because it's
anxiogenic it increases anxiety
at that point you start to ruminate this
Rolodex of anxiety begins to whirl and
you start to then
ruminate and when you ruminate you
catastrophize because everything seems
so much worse in the darkness of night
than it does in the light of day and at
that point of catastrophizing and
ruminating you're sort of dead in the
water for the next two hours as it were
stir in my life yeah I'm so sorry it's
gonna sound pain for me familiar to many
people out there
so that's one of the issues with
caffeine the other is its duration of
action you mentioned it's
pharmacokinetics
it has a half-life of what we call five
to six hours which is just a fancy way
of saying that after about five to six
hours half of the caffeine still in your
system which means that caffeine has a
quarter life of for the average adult at
least 10 to 12 hours
and I it's probably again not really a
very good analogy but you know if you
have a cup of coffee let's say at 1pm or
2 p.m in the afternoon
is it similar to then saying well that's
the equivalent of tucking myself into
bed at midnight before I switch the
light out I swing a quarter of a cup of
coffee and I I hope for a good night of
sleep it's probably not going to happen
because a quarter of the caffeine is
still in the brain swirling around
at midnight so its duration of action is
something that people may want to be
mindful of and that will impact sleep
the other component is that caffeine
will
destabilize your sleep so it makes your
sleep more fragile and as a consequence
if you are prone to waking up and we all
will wake up across the night even
healthy good sleepers will wake up
because caffeine will destabilize and
make your sleep more fragile it's more
likely that you'll wake up and when you
do wake up your sleep is less robust and
it's harder for you to fall back asleep
and so now sleep maintenance insomnia
and then the final part of caffeine
comes back to deep sleep
if we and we've done these studies where
we can dose people at different times of
the day and into the evening and if you
give people a standardized dose of
caffeine maybe 150 180 or 200 milligrams
which would be suppose the equivalent of
probably a very strongly dripped brewed
cup of coffee or probably
one and a half cups of coffee
what we can see is a decrease in the
amount of Deep non-rem Sleep
particularly in the first two hours of
the night it can decimate that that deep
sleep
in fact there was a reduction if you
look at that and we've done some of
these Studies by a single cup of coffee
in the evening it will drop the amount
of deep sleep by about 30 percent 3-0
which to put that in context I would
probably have to age you by about 12 to
14 years to get that type of reduction
in your deep sleep or you could just do
it every night with an espresso if you
wanted to and I do think that that's
relevant by the way some people will say
look I can have a cup of coffee within
or even two and I can fall asleep find
and I stay asleep so no harm no foul
the problem there is that it discounts
the idea that you have no sense of how
much deep sleep that you get at night
yes you probably remember did you
struggle to fall asleep or did you wake
up but none of us has a recollection of
the quality of our deep slow brainwave
activity
but yet you may still be suffering from
that excising of a significant amount of
your deep sleep and so the next morning
you don't feel refreshed or restored by
your sleep but you don't remember
struggling to fall asleep or having a
hard time staying asleep and so you
discount the idea that it was the coffee
the next night but now you start
reaching for three cups of coffee the
next morning
and then so on and so forth the sort of
vicious cycle Begins the harder it is
the next night to fall asleep the less
deep sleep the more coffee you get and
then people start falling into the Trap
of alcohol or sleeping aids so so let me
hop in let me hop in I'm gonna stage the
intervention all right so so the cycle
the stimulant depressant cycle is is a
whole mess I've been a active
participant on that field before
but if I could just return to some of
the questions that kicked us off
so why
why allow
or endorse the idea of a cup of coffee
in the morning number one right if if it
is after this Litany of of sins
and then how could coffee be associated
with any of the health benefits of sleep
and if so how is that the case
you're absolutely right I think you know
the time when I was writing the book a
few years ago the evidence was starting
to emerge there that
drinking coffee had health benefits and
there's been some great meta-analyzes
quite recently and it is striking and
you just can't really deny it on the
strength of the evidence that drinking
coffee is associated with numerous
health benefits and the reduction in
risk for numerous health conditions and
what's striking as you mentioned
elegantly is that many of the same
health related conditions that drinking
coffee
is associated with reducing are the very
same
diseases that sleep will also reduce in
terms of your risk so how on Earth does
this work they seem completely
paradoxical
the answer is antioxidants
because it turns out that the Coffee
Bean itself contains much more than just
caffeine it contains a very healthy dose
of antioxidants
a family called the polyphenols perhaps
the principal one is
well there's a number of different
polyphenols that it contains
but chlorogenic acids are probably the
the principal kind that we think carry
to an ester that carries some of these
health benefits so what we realized is
that the Coffee Bean because most people
in developed nations are still deficient
in their whole food dietary intake The
Humble Coffee Bean has been asked to
carry the Herculean weight of all of our
antioxidant needs and that's why
drinking coffee has this such a strong
statistical Health signal in the data
when you do epidemiological studies so
it's not the caffeine that's related to
the health benefits it's the
antioxidants and case in point if you
look at decaffeinated coffee you get
many of the same I was just going to say
I hate to spoil the party with a
question
if I could jump in for a second just a
quick side note so the
antioxidants and nutritional value of
coffee being in let's just say
less industrialized or lower income
strata of various countries is true also
for Coca in the Peruvian Andes and
elsewhere it's actually a source of
very important nutrition for for a lot
of these communities and Indigenous
groups so I just wanted to say that as
an aside also chlorogenic acid I think
is contained in other
quite a few other compounds and and
beverages if I'm not mistaken so I I
want to say that it's
present in yerba mate which they drink
all the time in Argentina I may be
getting that wrong so somebody can fact
check me but is chlorogenic acid found
in like Camellia senensis tea plants or
or other types of of beverages or is it
particularly prevalent in coffee
no you can't find it it's certainly
nowhere near exclusive to the Coffee
Bean itself yeah by the way it doesn't
have contain any chloride please don't
be worried about it you're drinking in
you know bleach or something like that
it's got nothing to do with that but yet
the chlorogenic acids that's certainly
one group it's not to say it's the only
group though there are others
acromide is another one that we've been
very interested in in terms of the
Coffee Bean which is another antioxidant
so it's a cluster of different
antioxidants that provide these benefits
any Brewing methods roasts grinds any
combination of those variables that if
one wanted to maximize for the good
stuff and minimize
the the potential damage to sleep and
sleep architecture
any thoughts on on what that Goldilocks
combination might look like
it is interesting and by the way I think
the Goldilocks combination comes on to
the idea that you know when it comes to
coffee it's the dose and the timing that
make the poison here yeah that you know
obviously and if you look at the health
benefits too once you get past about two
and a half three cups of coffee a day
the health benefits start to go down in
the opposite direction so it's not a
linear relationship don't start drinking
like seven cups of coffee and be mindful
of the timing but to come to your
question
I suppose if we're talking about
caffeine concentration and then maybe
antioxidant concentration
actually here I am going to do a feature
today I'm going to do a two by three
because you could think about the rows
of the this table being the caffeine and
the antioxidants and then the columns
three columns would be the roast maybe
of the Coffee Bean the grind of the
coffee being the granularity the
coarseness and then maybe the Brewing
method
it's not quite as simple as this but
certainly what we found is that for the
roast of the Coffee Bean and this comes
onto the color of the coffee bean a
coffee bean is a coffee bean in terms of
its
when it comes out what changes its color
is is how you roast it and what we found
is that
sort of gram for gram light roast
actually has about the same caffeine
content as dark roast but the issue is
that the dark roast the longer that you
roast it the more degraded The Coffee
Bean becomes and hence the lighter its
density so net net on average a lighter
roast will contain more caffeine than a
darker roast so it's a it's a little bit
complex in terms of the grind I think
it's fairly clear that fine grain coffee
produces a higher degree of caffeine
concentration than a coarse grain
now of course we're not talking about
Brewing methods yet but that's simply
probably on the basis of surface area
that the finer the grain the greater the
surface area the greater the release of
the caffeine
Brewing method is it's really
interesting if you look at some of the
data the longer the Brewing method the
greater the caffeine concentration
relative to shorter
also cold Brews tend to produce a
stronger caffeine content than hot Brews
I think part of that simply is down to
the duration of the Brew itself cold
Brews typically take longer and
therefore you you get a stronger pound
for the punch in terms of caffeine
so that's caffeine antioxidants
in terms of the chlorogenic acids
you're you're probably going to favor
lighter rather than darker roasts
lighter roasts typically have higher
amounts of chlorogenic acid
than darker roasts although
there is some evidence that dog roasts
have higher amounts of some of the other
antioxidants like
acromide for example you don't need to
worry too much in terms of the
antioxidants and also by the way
thankfully the decaffeinating process
still preserves the antioxidants and
that's why it's still related to the
health benefits you don't lose out on
the antioxidants when you switch to
decaffeinated
finer grains typically produce more
antioxidants than also grind in terms of
that and then Brewing method
it's probably that cold brew seems to
produce stronger antioxidant
concentrations than probably the next
down would be espresso preparation then
instantly instant
coffee seems to have finally higher
concentrations of antioxidants than drip
or sort of infusion bag versions so I'm
sure that I'll stand corrected by the
internet but that's sort of my reading
[Music]
perfect so let's go from one socially
acceptable
psychoactive to one that is certainly
becoming more and more socially
acceptable that I'd like to ask about
next and that is cannabis broadly
speaking but specifically in this case
CBD THC and then potentially CBN if you
have any thoughts on it because it is
commonly sold as for sleep
but I don't know how much that is
supported in any way so let's talk about
the
CBD THC and this is of personal interest
to me because I find that THC
specifically helps me tremendously with
turning down the volume on the
rumination that tends to be associated
with
really horrible sleep onset insomnia it
tones down the chatter tremendously for
me and I find that at least subjectively
to be one of the primary reasons it
helps me to sleep however I've often
wondered if I'm taking say smaller what
I would consider smaller doses in the
forms of Edibles which are then
converted through first pass metabolism
into other things but
at 2.5 milligrams or 5 milligrams or
seven and a half milligrams am I
inhibiting my REM sleep coming back to
what you said earlier like sometimes you
don't know what you don't know because
you're not immediately aware of how much
REM sleep you're getting unless you're
tracking it using some type of biometric
device
am I screwing myself in the long term by
using this Aid in the short term right
so that's the context but please please
in any way that makes sense tell us what
you know about CBD THC and anything else
related to this fine plan
so there's probably more research that
we have right now on THC which is the
psychoactive component of cannabis
but there is some fairly interesting
data on cbd2 and a little significantly
less data on CBN
the THC so it we have a set of
cannabinoid receptors in the brain both
What's called the CB1 receptor and the
CB2 receptor the CB1 receptor is the
primary one that's expressed in the
brain that's where we think THC is
having its sleep effects
and so
what we've found and by the way if you
go back some of the first writings the
first emergence of this story of THC for
sleep at least from what I found came
from the writings of This brilliant
British position
Dr Clan dining and he published his
first monographs in
1843 I think it was and if you read it
oh I think you would love it too much I
should send you some of these before it
was cool wow yeah before it was cool and
it was like this hemp resin that he was
talking about but just the writing
itself you would love it's this
wonderful oh gosh I wish I could write
that way but his writing is lovely and
delicious and I could read it all
weekend but he just he was the first to
describe some soporific and sedating
benefits of hemp resin and then another
doctor the same year oh Shaughnessy
published some evidence too what we
probably know of
four things related to THC with a
possible caveat the first is that you
get a Fairly reliable very nice
reduction in the time it takes you to
fall asleep this is just what you're
describing too it seems to have sedative
benefit and we're starting to unpack and
understand exactly why THC has that sort
of sedating effect
the next issue however isn't quite such
Rosy news that you seem to develop
tolerance which is that the same dose if
you're using it chronically consistently
every single night can in some
individuals lead to
a tolerance that means that you have to
increase the dose and therefore you
develop a dependency and I think the way
if people want to test dependency would
be to say look if I have to let's say
travel internationally and I'm I
obviously don't want to you know Transit
unless it drugs into other countries if
if they're not legal there then would I
start to just get very anxious I would
think well my goodness I've lost my
crutch of THC and at that point it
probably demonstrates that there is a
dependency that you have on it which I'd
prefer or wish for people not to have
necessarily
the the third feature of THC
is that it has quite a significant
withdrawal rebound effect so when people
stop using THC they typically don't just
go back to the bad sleep that they were
having before it's often even worse do
we have any idea of the
dosage range that we're talking about
right because you could develop
DT and Tremors and so on from alcohol
withdrawal but that's not going to
happen if you're having one glass of
wine per night so in this particular
case with
THC
how much does one need to be taking or
do we know on a consistent let's just
say nightly basis
to experience that type of
rebound that would be so harmful
to sleep do we know I wish I had an
answer and we currently just simply
don't know okay automatic studies right
now it's more simply service but it's
observable like it can happen but it's
very I mean it's so observable it's so
reliable this rebound insomnia
withdrawal that it forms part of the DSM
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders the sort of Psychiatry
Bible it forms part of the criteria
symptoms for cannabis withdrawal this
insomnia syndrome that's how
consistently reliable it is it's part of
the diagnostic criteria and in fact
often it's the insomnia that happens
when you stop using that is one of the
Prime reasons for remittance that people
will then go back to using it because
they just dislike the insomnia so much
and so go back to the wacky tobacco they
can't stay away
and then the other aspect is that it
seems to why significantly disrupt your
REM sleep and it does it in three ways
the first is that it will decrease the
overall amount of REM sleep that you're
getting the second is that it delays the
arrival of the first episode of REM
sleep in this cycling
the nature of sleep
and then the third aspect of that is it
seems to decrease the intensity of rapid
eye movement sleep and the way that one
of the ways that we measure that is just
how many of these eye movements that's
where it gets its name by the way rapid
eye movement sleep because your eyes
stop back and forth and the more of
those rapid eye movements that you're
having the more intense the REM sleep
and in fact the more intense the
dreaming and THC will decrease the
intensity that metric of
REM sleep too
I think perhaps the more powerful piece
of evidence for me looking at the
literature that it is REM sleep
disruptive is less about the amount of
the quality of the REM sleep as you're
using but what happens when you stop
using which is all of a sudden you get a
rebound effect where you start to get
significantly more REM sleep when you
stop using THC and that's a
demonstration of scientist that we would
say is a homeostatic response which is
that if you deprive yourself of
something when you get the chance to get
it you get an increase in the amount
there is a response and that increase
that homeostatic rebound effect is
usually a sign of a deficiency that's
been happening before that does that
make sense Tim it does make sense and if
you could allow me to sort of indulge
myself for a second here
I would say that in my personal
experiences is the end of one anecdote
and I understand that but
I've also used sleep trackers right so
I've used various devices I have
observed over and over again with more
or less a hundred percent predictability
the destructive effects of alcohol it's
so obvious feel miserable the next day
you see it in the numbers it's just
sort of incontrovertible evidence that
alcohol is not friends with my sleep at
least the quality of my sleep yeah now
on the other hand and I say this as
someone
who only began experimenting with
cannabis a few years ago so I am not a
lifelong pothead this is not a religion
to me
I have no identity wrapped up in
cannabis whatsoever and for the for the
most part I had a very low opinion of
cannabis because I saw so many people
become
unproductive through overuse of cannabis
over the decades
but
I have seen
incredible effects on sleep and I've not
observed at least at the dose the dosing
that I'm using and as you mentioned you
know paracelsus the dose makes the
poison you need to be careful with the
dosing on all these things including
water for instance but
it hasn't seemed to inhibit my REM sleep
and I suppose there's also a question
that comes to mind which is well let's
say it inhibited your REM sleep or
hypothetically on average it reduced REM
sleep
10 percent
if it took you from 90 minutes to fall
asleep to 15 minutes to fall asleep
could that end up in an absolute
increase in your REM sleep even if
theoretically it would decrease it
percentage-wise 10 if that makes any
sense at all
how would you suggest we we think about
this because the
dosing has always been a question for me
like how much how much does it take and
I could also just do an N of one
experiment where I I do some on off as
you mentioned to try to observe what
happens but do we have any literature to
point us in any direction with respect
to what type of dosing starts to
suppress we don't right now in terms of
looking at a dose response curve we
probably have that dose response curve
when it comes to the benefit of reducing
the time it takes you to fall asleep and
the once you probably going up starting
at 2.5 milligrams all the way up to 20
milligrams there is that sedating effect
and we start to understand why there is
that now do we have that same data for
REM sleep we don't
simply that if you look at acute studies
where you bring individuals into the lab
often the Cannabis naive individuals you
dose them with THC and just bake the
[ __ ] out of them
you know they are seeing you know
visions of biblical characters in The
Sleep laboratory before you put them to
sleep no so you can give them these I
would say cut that part out leave it in
please do absolutely leave it in there
so all we have are these acute cities
where when you dose acutely you also
certainly get that reduction that
decrease in the amount of REM sleep
that's Fairly reliable fully consistent
what we don't have other studies where
we will then say do a longitudinal study
where we keep dosing people across a
month and we track the evolution of
these REM sleep impairments could it be
that there is
some also some homeostatic pushback were
gradually the brain starts to fight back
against the deprivation of REM and turn
up the volume on REM sleep generation
and therefore you you don't see the
effects long term the only reason I I
would predict that that's not the case
is when you speak to lots of people
who are chronic cannabis users and they
say that they stopped after you know one
year two years they will say I just
started to have all of these crazy
intense dreams as soon as I stopped
smoking yeah and it's so common and so I
think at that point it still tells me
that the brain has been it was bereft of
REM sleep throughout that period it was
undernourished and by way of that
nutrient deprivation of REM sleep it had
built up this increasing hunger and
desire for REM where as soon as you
stopped the blocking agent which is the
THC it comes back with the Vengeance
that I think is the only evidence that I
know of right now that still tells me it
probably is having a suppressing REM
sleep effect
yeah and I will say that I have met a
number of chronic users who have told me
some version of I haven't remembered a
dream in 10 years
and then they stop and begin having
these extremely vivid dreams and
to your point and it does seem to have
that effect I have not personally
observed it I think that may also
be partially due to the fact that I try
or historically I have tried to cycle on
and off very deliberately to avoid the
development of Tolerance
and I have to imagine that that helps on
on some level how does CBD fit into
things
if at all it is an interesting emerging
story so CBD which is the sort of the
non-psychoactive component of that
firstly emerged on the Sleep map
probably in the 1970s much later than in
THC in the literature
it's actually really interesting they
were studying they were dosing pigeons
Tim would you believe it with all of
these different compounds and they were
looking at the learning ability of it
turns out pigeons are actually very
smart you can teach them things like the
alphabet and they were dosing them in
the 70s with different compounds one of
them was with
a CBD
I'm imagining this experimenter you know
like the pi the going to the IRB and
they're like can we do this in humans
they're like no okay can we do this in
monkeys no
cats no rats no what the hell could we
do this then all right we'll give you
pigeons and they're like ah fine we'll
do it in pictures yeah I know people
seem to think of pigeons as kind of like
you know rats with wings you know oh
sure you can sort of work on them so
they were looking at
pigeons of old I would love to kind of
be able to say that I'm a sleep
scientist and my specialty is in pigeon
sleep but they were studying pigeons and
what they found was that with CBD
exclusively the at higher doses I should
say The Waking Life of those pigeons
became a lot less wakeful they started
to demonstrate the expression of slowed
motoric movements their learning starts
to become worse they demonstrated signs
of drowsiness
now by the way they weren't high they
weren't getting these pigeons baked
because there was no THC it was just
right with DVD components so that was
the first evidence that we that we had
if you look at the human stuff
I don't think there's anywhere near
enough data to go on record to suggest
that CBD is the Shangri-La of good sleep
at night
it's mixed right now but
I think the story is that in higher
doses CBD does seem to be able to
potentially increase the amount of deep
non-rem sleep that one gets if you look
at some of the studies
the concern though is that CBD seems to
have a bimodal distribution and what I
mean by that is in lower Doses and again
I don't think there's any there's good
enough science to tell you exactly what
those doses are but perhaps if you
squint your eyes and you kind of look at
it slightly sideways maybe it's about 25
milligrams or less of CBD and again I'm
this is not me being Medical in terms of
my advice or anything like that as you
said this is simply me being descriptive
on the basis of the scientific data not
prescriptive in terms of medical right
but less than 25 milligrams you actually
get awake promoting effect where CPD
will actually make you more alert yeah
exactly
whereas in higher doses maybe perhaps 50
milligrams or above it may have some
sleep inducing effects part of the
reason that I think there's a lot of
variability out there is that at least
here in the United States it's it's not
FDA regulated and there's a lot of
variability from one batch and if it
really is so dose sensitive dependent
that there's this u-shaped function then
you could be thinking well the bottle is
telling me I take 50 milligrams every
night and some nights God I struggle
with sleep another night I get knocked
out and I don't understand it's it's not
consistent
so
that's the reason I think there is some
emerging evidence that gets me more
excited about CBD
and for myself I think perhaps other
scientists for a long time we were a
little bit sort of puritanical about THC
and CBD well it's an illicit drug and
you know you don't want to do it but I
think in truth you can't just as a
scientist sit it out and say well it's
illicit and therefore I'm going to
discount it I think you need to put your
feet in the trenches and get your hands
dirty and so I've actually decided to
start working with a proper clinical
outfit from a group in Imperial College
in London and we're really trying to
actually dig in and create a proper
clinical based CBD compound and do the
studies if it's really real or not and
it's a particular CBD analog obviously
they've got a patent on it but we really
want to look at this so we're going to
do proper studies phase one phase two
phase three studies and try and pull out
all of the nonsense there but if you
were to then say well what is it about
CBD if it does have a sleep benefit that
would be helpful because we know some of
the ways in which THC is quote unquote
helpful for sleep and we also know how
it's harmful to your REM sleep what
about CBD
for CBD I think there's probably at
least two mechanisms that I I get become
thoughtful about one is indirect the
other is direct the first is that CBD is
a very powerful or quite a significant
anxiolytic that it seems to reduce down
anxiety and there's great science using
brain scanning technology this has got
nothing to do with sleep but where you
dose people with CBD and inside the
brain scanner you can see a reduction in
the
sort of the emotional sentence regions
like the amygdala that light up CBD will
decrease those so I think as we
mentioned before anxiety is a roadblock
it's a good sleep and if you remove that
anxiety sleep arrive to you on that
Royal Road in a slightly more kindly
fashion so that's one way it's an
anxiolytic the second is a direct
pathway that if you dose rats with CBD
it drops their core body temperature so
CBD seems to be hypothermic yeah and as
I said we need to drop our core body
temperature to get colder and so I think
that's the other plausible route if it
does benefit sleep that I would hang my
hat on
so on the hypothermic side one study I
would love to see someone do and studies
cost money and they cost a lot of money
and they take a long time often as you
know and but the potential
combination therapy of
MDMA and
some type of
cannabis derivative probably not whole
plant but whether it's THC CBD or CBD by
itself or or THC by itself because
and people will take issue with this I'm
sure but one of the risks
if you go to any uncontrolled
environment where MDMA is consumed at a
festival or otherwise and you go to the
medical triage teams you will find
people who are overheating that is one
of the
primary risks of excessive MDMA intake
so could you not just mitigate some of
the physiological risk but also improve
clinical outcomes by combining the two I
haven't seen anything on this but I did
about a year ago a bunch of reading on
both looking at if that could not only
stem some of the risk factors but also
enhance clinical outcomes now I will say
that on the con side one of the counter
arguments would be that
cannabis can sometimes have an amnesic
effect on people and if you were doing
it in a clinical setting where you want
to have recall that could be an issue if
you're with a therapist they should also
be doing a lot of the recording and so
on so you might end up in neutral if
you're taking you know methylene dioxy
methamphetamine which by the way one one
could say would improve recall on some
people
then maybe you just end up kind of Net
Zero at Baseline but depending on the
dosing I just haven't seen much research
done with it so I'd be curious at some
point
side note what is your
just for everyone listening and for
myself your handle on Twitter
what is your username on Twitter on
Twitter you can find me at sleep
Diplomat
that's right I chose not to use my own
name because you know I'm quite shy and
I typically a little bit private but and
also it's not about me it's about sleep
and so I want to remove my name
sleep Diplomat all right so at sleep
Diplomat and I at T Ferris tfer or ISS
actually I don't want to speak for you
Matt but I'll speak for myself
I'm at sleep loudmouth and he's at sleep
yeah Diplomat no I'm at T Ferris so at T
Ferris with two rs2s's I would like to
hear from people out there
who fall into a few camps one would be
researchers who have looked very closely
at this literature
scientists or even amateur scientists
who have the technical ability to at
least read studies well
to see what's out there or what people
would like to do from a research
perspective
and the second group I would love to
hear from are self-trackers people in
the Quantified Self movement or who are
using devices like the aura ring or
others who may have data
from their own measurements related to
say THC and or CBD consumption and how
that has affected
REM sleep as an example I would be so
interested to know if if anyone is
willing to share that
specifically dosage dosage range and
whether or not they have observed
it to interfere with REM sleep would be
super interesting so I would love to do
that please Loop me in on that because I
think we can probably crowd Source a
good amount of that you know data will
it be scientific of course
it's not going to necessarily be
scientific but it's a little bit like
Amazon reviews you know if this product
that has 30 000 reviews and it's 4.9
Stars you probably don't need the
science to suggest that it's going to be
a fairly decent product and so thank you
for for sort of expressing that I would
love to be included in that yeah then
people can just tag both of us on
Twitter with what they have found and I
would say furthermore that some of the
self-tracking can go a long way I I I
don't want to make too strong a case but
I have seen I'm not going to name names
but I've when I was much younger I
volunteered as a subject in scientific
studies all over the place in it
including at some very well-known
universities because I wanted to see how
it was done I wanted to see how various
studies were conducted and I will say
that there is high variability in how
tightly
experiments are run and some of them
with very small subject sizes can be run
quite sloppily and the when the output
is very precise and it's like a p-value
out to four decimal points and this then
the other thing it can create the
illusion of being much more compelling
or at least more accurate than it might
be and that's not to malign all of
science they're great scientists out
there I fund a lot of them but there's
also
The Good the Bad and the Ugly in the
realm of of experiment design and
execution on the other hand if you have
let's just say an N of a thousand people
who claim to be using THC at a certain
dosage range
it's unlikely that all of them are lying
right so even if you account for some
degree of of fudge Factor it can at the
very least be very useful in formulating
more precise hypotheses that you can
then test I've felt this way for a long
time since predating the four hour body
I went to the first Quantified Self
Meetup ever I think it was 12 people at
Kevin Kelly's house in Pacifica in 2008
and it's still very very fertile ground
Let Me Take A Hard left turn if I could
for a second and ask you a question that
has been on my mind since I first read
your book there was passing mention of
this and I'm not looking at my highlight
this is from memory so I apologize if
if this is something that came to me in
a fever dream and it's not even in the
book but I feel like I read a passage
that said something along the lines of
rocking having a bed that rocks or
having a rocking motion
has been
experimentally or at least
observationally determined to improve
some facet of Sleep Quality or duration
and it prompted me to think why are more
people not spending time on this if
that's if that is the case am I making
this up is this just a figment of my
imagination
there's nothing wrong with your memory
it's it's wonderfully Exquisite that's
what we found you know you think of it
comes from the early Inception of
parents that they would take their child
and they would rock them back and forth
and it seemed to have a sleep inducing
benefit and then you'd get cradles where
you would rock the cradle so there
seemed to be something about the rocking
motion
and so then there were a group of
scientists from the University of Geneva
who conducted a brilliant City it was
one of those studies that I was just so
envious that I didn't do the study and I
didn't know the idea and what they did
was they essentially took a bed frame
and a mattress and they suspended it
from the ceiling rather than planting it
on the floor
on these sort of chains which starts to
sound very s m and please stick with me
it's not I'm not quite doing that oh I'm
on the same page I'm ready for it yeah
maybe that's the conversation we have
after we start recording but so yeah
there's no candle wax on the nipples
nothing like that that's involved in
this city so there's never say never
this funding for it all right Tim you're
a great guy
so they they got the bed and they
suspended it from the the ceiling and
then they put this device this
oscillating device that would
essentially sort of rock the bed in a
lateral fashion left and right so just
so I'm envisioning this properly
laterally would mean if I'm laying on
the bed I would be moving side to side
my left or right that's right yep so
you'd be sort of Shifting towards your
left side and your right side it's as if
you're on a boat and it's sort of you
know or in a hammock exactly in a
hammock much better visual so they
started to rock the bed and they were
rocking it at a frequency that was
trying to match those deep slow brain
waves so those deep slow brain waves
they go the reason they're called slow
brain waves is because they go up and
down maybe once or twice every second
which for brainwave activity is actually
very slow now when you and I are both
awake it's going up and down maybe 30 40
50 times a second so it's very very very
slow they were trying to match that
frequency of brainwave with the rotating
Rock of the bed back and forth the
oscillation back and forth and what they
found was that lo and behold they were
able to increase the amount of those
deep slow brain waves by rocking the bed
back and forth they also increased
another brain oscillation that's
associated with deep sleep which is
called and with non-rem sleep which is
called a sleep spindle which are these
incredible bursts of electrical activity
that ride like Surfers on the top of
these slow brain waves they increase
those as well and they also demonstrated
that their learning in memory function
the next day was improved and we may
speak about learning in memory with
sleep so in other words it wasn't just
an Epi phenomenon but it wasn't simply
just Epi phenomenologically that you
increase deep sleep and it doesn't
really mean anything you increased it
and it has a functional outcome which
was better memory as a consequence so so
I believe there is a company that has
I saw them a couple of years ago I don't
know where they're at that develops
these little feet that you then Place
underneath the frame of your bed and
their mechanical feet and they will
start to try and sort of rock the bed
back and forth on the basis of this
scientific literature now whether or not
that that's making any difference I I
don't know I haven't seen any evidence
but you're right there was that paper in
it yeah as soon as I came across that I
was thinking
why isn't why have I not seen more
companies
looking at this because you could try to
I'm going to use a word that's going to
get people to laugh at me but you so
taking say the bed that we have and
putting it on these feet or the Rockers
I could see working I would actually be
very interested in testing that but it's
also skeuomorphic in the sense that
we're trying to take something we know
and slightly modify it with a new
technology to make it work
but we could take something that most of
the world is very familiar with but
Americans are perhaps less accustomed to
using and those are hammocks right I
mean all throughout the tropics hammocks
everywhere and
you could have a very lightweight system
that you could set up in the home there
I can think of a number of different
configurations and you would just need a
mechanism by which you could perpetuate
the rocking and establish a Cadence
right but I mean yeah you you could
ostensibly have a system that you could
put in a suitcase and travel with in
that case right I mean it's it's it got
me very excited because I have had and
I'm not saying this is the same thing
but some of the best sleep in my life in
hammocks in the tropics and there are a
million other factors I get it this
isn't a controlled experiment but you
can also take a hammock and fold it up
into something that you could I mean
stick inside a large jacket pocket I
mean there are such hammocks they're so
easy and to set up and so easy to move
around so anyway that was just
scratching my own Edge no I think it's a
very interesting idea and it's one that
I've also had to to myself so I sort of
you throw out these plan or you develop
these patterns with this sort of you
know sci-fi knowledge but I I did this
anyway because another way you could
stimulate the sensation of rocking is
not by physically rocking but by having
a small inner ear device that will
actually stimulate the the Machinery
within the eardrum itself like the
vestibular system correct so it would be
fast
that's wild about this patent that I
sort of wrote Because I sort of had this
idea you know it is a Sci-Fi okay try
and be an academic be a podcaster you
know help some startup companies teach
and research and then also you know do
some of these other things and and by
the way make sure you get your eight
plus hours of sleep so I put this
together because I think that that's
another interesting way that you could
do it I don't have to physically rock
you because you could imagine that you
know perhaps if people are in couples
that they don't necessarily want to get
into a bed and some people like rocking
other people don't but I'm talking about
the physical yeah I'm getting myself
into trouble you get the what I'm trying
to say yeah I get I get it there's some
point there that you may not wish to do
the physical movement and the rocking up
so why don't you just get these little
devices you could put them in the ear
and you could travel with them too and
it will just stimulate the vestibular
system fool your brain into thinking
that it's rocking could I do that also
then could I do it even more carefully
when that device that I put into the ear
also has a sensor because it turns out
that you can pick up electrical
brainwave activity that is bleed over
and it comes down into the ear so I
could actually measure your brain waves
not by sticking electrodes on your head
but just simply with the inner ear
device alone then I can measure the
sweet spot of your own sort of Da Vinci
Code frequency of slow wave sleep and
then I can match the vestibular
stimulation to your individual sort of
unique slow oscillation
so that's I so I've got no I'm just
imagining you on late night television
selling The Da Vinci Code magic sleep
device
you may run you may you may run into
some trademark issues but you know what
let them chase let them chase you if you
ever see me doing that please just come
over and extinguish my life with with
rapidity that I would be most grateful
for never do I want to become the George
Foreman of gorilla of sleep oh my
goodness
[Applause]
so how far in would this need to go in
your ear and is it something you could
easily remove or is it an implant I
guess I'm wondering is it some type of
I'm thinking of the beetle it's not
really a beetle it's like this strange
alien
creepy crawly millipede type thing in
the Wrath of Khan I think it was the
star deck 2 movie that crawls in your
ear but is this something you could put
in and take out or is it something
that's implanted that you turn on and
off what does it look like no I think it
would be put in take out and in fact I
was at
conference some years ago and I'd
already put together the pattern but I
think the maybe the military maybe it
was darker the sort of the advanced
component of the American Military
technology agency they had already
developed something that was quite like
this and the reason that they were using
it was as a silent method for directing
soldiers in terms of the direction of
progression at a particular special ops
location and so where you don't want any
communication you don't want to sort of
put out there any signals they were just
using this in here to say go left go
right go front go back and so that
technology is I think is out there and
they've developed some of that can we
just turn it to sleep anyway crazy ideas
so side note on DARPA if people want to
see a an incredible I mean just
mind-boggling
many many multi-decade long track record
of innovation study DARPA it's it is
unbelievable I mean if you invent the
internet you get free license to do a
lot of stuff but
take a look at DARPA and if anybody can
recommend a really good book or
long-form article that describes
Innovation at DARPA please let me know
also on Twitter I'd like to come back to
the glymphatic system for a moment and
I I don't want to attribute this to
anyone but I've spoken to a number of
very credible researchers who
are now heavily engaged with psychedelic
compounds and I phrase that carefully
because it's they're not exclusively
psychedelic researchers these are
world-class researchers who are now
directing their attention to certain
psychedelic compounds
not that there's anything wrong with
people who Focus exclusively I am very
fond of a number of excellent scientists
who do incredible work who might fit
that description however
the point I want to make is that in
conversation I want to say they
described how
some of these psychedelics and I want to
say we're talking about the serotonergic
classical psychedelics or at least
psychedelics that affect the type 2A
receptor
and how they impact microglia in the
glymphatic system which then raises
questions
about what long-term impact
that might have with a certain frequency
of administration hypothetically on
let's just say the longevity of some of
the cortical structures we were talking
about earlier would there be the
potential of staving off or slowing the
onset of some of these generative
conditions I happen to be very
and look I'm talking at a turn here I I
couldn't prove this but I happen to be
very bullish on this I think it's worth
exploring at least
are there other means by which
people can
ensure the proper functioning of their
glymphatic system if they want to ensure
they are
facilitating this this self-repair and
cellular cleaning in the brain are there
any other
any other levers people can pull any
other things that people can do or not
do that you're aware of
I think right now sleep seems to be the
the big one important of those but I
think there's also some emerging
evidence that physical activity and I.E
exercise
can increase the the efficiency of that
system but to come back to your question
about psychedelics I think
I would love to examine what's going on
with sleep during the treatment phases
well actually I would like to look at it
both pre-post and during because one
could imagine is there something about
the Integrity of your sleep as you go
into those therapeutic experiences that
sets you up for and is deterministic of
the efficacy success of that in other
words
it's it's a little bit like the evidence
for sleep and the immune system and
vaccination that if you're not getting
sufficient sleep in the week before you
get your flu shot you'll produce less
than 50 percent of the normal antibody
response rendering that flu shot
significantly less effective and by the
way we've found similar evidence most
recently with the covid shot as well so
is there something similar like that but
upstairs in the brain when it comes to
the therapeutic effects of MDMA that if
you're seeding the brain with sufficient
sleep before does it predict certain
outcomes second I don't think we really
understand in detail at least not in
this kind of
web.2 or sort of the second coming of
these psychedelic compounds with the
hard science that's now really there I
don't think we've got good data on sleep
there are some age-old cities back in
the 60s and the 70s looking at different
psychoactive components and how they
would impact your sleep but I would love
to see science and be involved in that
if there's people doing these types of
studies I I should probably have more
conversations with them and see if we
can just get some even light Lite
versions of sleep tracking in those to
see what's going on and then also what
happens afterwards what happens to your
sleep as a consequence of that treatment
is part of the long-term trajectory
because it helps re-establish
re-stabilize re-energize sleep does it
impact and harm sleep and that to me
would be even more interesting that you
can get
an emotional therapeutic benefit despite
disruptions in sleep yeah be wonderful
to learn that too
so let's talk about this we'll do I'm
not sure I'm using this correctly maybe
maybe the Germans can come in and and
say yay or nay or ya or nine as the case
might be good Duncan let's do a good
donkey or two a good Duncan as I like to
say sorry yeah we'll approach it by me
sharing a number of
observations
patterns that I've recognized just
having been involved in
the discourse around psychedelics for a
reasonably long time now I mean since
publicly probably since 2014 or 15 maybe
a bit earlier and then have have been
immersed in it for quite a bit longer
the first is that well let me say a few
things so with MDMA given that it is
effectively a methamphetamine
people generally don't sleep at all
afterwards like sleep is terrible it's
awful
which would be just as a side note
another possible
Pro argument for a combination therapy
using THC
and I won't go into too much of the
personal details on that but that that
would be a I think a compelling reason
to do research looking at that as a
combination therapy with the classical
psychedelics
it's a flashback let me give a flashback
my sophomore year I want to say was my
sophomore might have been my junior year
sophomore or Junior year in college this
is a long time ago so it's like 96.97
and I put this paper online somewhere
and I don't think it's defensible
there's a lot of like
undergrad hand waving going on but I was
I was at Princeton
focused on becoming a
Psychology major with a focus on
neuroscience and I actually was able to
be a subject for some of Daniel
kahneman's studies while I was there so
you know pressing space bars a lot
looking at tons of screens which was was
actually really instructive but I wrote
a junior an either sophomore junior
paper on what appeared to be
similarities between
REM sleep and
LSD
Administration or consumption and what I
have now many decades later seen over
and over again is that people need less
sleep after psychedelic experiences
and
I would be curious to know how you might
explain that if we take that as true
they have this experience and then they
seem to require less sleep to me that
implies there may be similarities
between the two
but I would be curious to hear your
thoughts I'll give you another
I don't want to say data point because I
realize this is all anecdotal but I've
seen this now replicated a whole bunch
of times
if some people and I'm not advising this
folks these are illegal in most places
still and schedule one can can really
ruin your day
so lots of legal risk and also a psycho
emotional and in some cases physical
risk but if if someone takes let's just
call it 250
to 500 milligrams of dried celosity
mushrooms
which would be considered not a
microdose so microdose might be in the
range of 50 to say 100 milligrams and
there's High degree of variability so
let's just assume that it's been finely
ground and mixed so it's been
homogenized somewhat in terms of
actual psilocybin content
a
solid session let's just say for someone
who is maybe an intermediate would
generally be in the three two
four and a half gram range
the Terence McKenna heroic dose is five
grams although some people go
significantly higher the clinical
studies of psilocybin are generally
using I want to say 25 to 30 milligrams
which would
simulate a roughly 5 gram experience so
now we're talking about one tenth of
that as the top end 500 milligrams and
you could actually go significantly
lower like 200 300 milligrams if someone
takes that immediately prior to sleep
what I have heard reported multiple
times now is in their dreams they have
what they would consider
a almost mirror experience of taking
five grams
outside of sleep in a waking state
then this isn't a hundred people but
it's enough now where there might
actually be something there what would
you make of any of this I think it's
fascinating some of these components
actually work neurochemically very
different to dream sleep so if you're
getting you know some of the similar
benefits and I the reason I say similar
benefits is because
Dream Sleeping REM sleeping we try to do
as much work as we can in this area does
provide a form of mental health benefit
provides a form of overnight therapy
that is during dream sleep when we strip
away emotion from memory and so we can
detox those emotional memories almost
like a nocturnal soothing bomb that sort
of takes the sharp edges off those
memories
and you come back the next day feeling
better about those things so in that
sense when it comes to dream sleep it's
not time that heals or wounds but it's
time during sleep and particularly
during REM sleep dreaming that provides
that form of emotional convalescence
so how does that then fit with some of
the Psychedelic stories
I think it fits because both of them
provide mental assistance benefits but
through I suspect very different
mechanisms many of those psychedelic
drugs will act on serotonergic
mechanisms within the brain
and in fact if you look at REM sleep
dreaming
it's the exact opposite and in fact you
mentioned the point where people were
sort of needing less sleep I wonder if
it's that they need less sleep or that
the brain is prevented from generating
sufficient sleep
and I don't know if we have the scalpel
to sort of systematically separate one
from the other there right now yeah but
if it does if they do produce both very
similar emotional health and mental
health benefits which I think is that's
what the evidence is suggesting they
both seem to do it I think
mechanistically they do it through two
different routes because during REM
sleep dreaming your brain shuts down
levels of two monoamines one is called
serotonin or five HT the other is
noradrenaline which everyone knows
downstairs in the body it's sister
chemicals name called adrenaline but
upstairs in the brain neurogen and so
I think mechanistically I'm fascinated
by these two questions that you owes
because they probably come through two
different routes but yet you arrive at
the same destination by way of two
different trajectories neurochemically
and mechanistically but then also what
does that mean in terms of sleep need
are we empowering the generation of
sleep by way of these compounds or we
simply because we're making up for what
sleep
produces naturally you relieve the
burden on sleep and so the homeostatic
drive for sleep is reduced and therefore
you don't need to sleep as much that
would be a stunning finding too yeah let
me throw out another wild aspect which I
probably should have mentioned up front
and that is when
people have experimented with these
let's just call it
two to five hundred usually on the lower
range two to three hundred milligram
pre-bed experiments
very often the report goes something
like this
holy [ __ ] that was intense that was like
I took five grams I feel like I didn't
sleep at all
but I'm not tired at all I actually feel
fully rested
and which relates to the first question
which is a valid question and that is
well if these are operating very
differently is it not reducing the need
for Sleep which is but rather inhibiting
your ability to sleep and I think that's
a very interesting question that also
can be entertained side by side with the
fact that when you do both at the same
time you have this very bizarre set of
outcomes
and I should say also I want to give
credit where credit is due the the
person who initially
galvanized a lot of my interest in the
scientific study of psychedelics was a
professor you might still be there named
Barry Jacobs at Princeton very
impressive a researcher and Professor
who also spent a lot of his time
studying cats because cats sleep all the
time
and was certainly studying a lot more
than psychedelics but I want to give him
a nod since looking at a lot of his work
and what he was doing which was really
pushing some incredible
boundaries at the time I had a lot of a
lot of respect for that
these are some outstanding questions
that I wish I really wish people would
take a look at and I do know there are
some people some groups who have tracked
their sleep post
experiences with say psilocybin
and
I would be curious to see any reports
from folks who have tracked over time on
off on off that type of data so once
again please send me a note on Twitter
if you have that not just a trip report
please as much as I want to hear about
the neon diamond encrusted crocodiles
that you rode across the waters to
Australia where you you know learn the
secrets of the universe what I'm most
interested in right now is oh you too
yeah that's yeah you too yeah graphs and
numbers graphs and numbers and once you
know what once you're lucky twice you're
good like back I know I'm misusing that
but like I don't want to I don't want to
see one example ideally someone who's
looked at it multiple times what I will
say is that
and I don't know what
effect this can have on sleep
or what relationship it has to sleep but
I have seen some evidence to suggest
that certain psychedelics can increase
heart rate variability
so that's that's another piece of the
puzzle that I haven't seen people
examine too too closely there may be a
few studies that have tracked it but I'm
not really aware of anyone that's done
it on mass all right that's my
musings with Tim gdunken on the
psychedelics let's talk for a second
about sleep
food intake
weight gain all that kind of good stuff
and part of the reason I wanted to ask
about this is because it seems this is
based on a comment that you had sent to
me a few days ago
about
and maybe you can tell me how to
pronounce this
endocannabinoids am I saying that
correctly cannabinoids yeah how do you
say this what's the proper pronunciation
on this endocannabinoids there we go on
endocannabinoids because I'm wondering
if this somehow ties into the earlier
conversation we were having about THC
Maybe not maybe it does but certainly
people who have smoked a lot of weed
which is not me but will be from the or
for that matter we've had enough Edibles
will be familiar with the munchies
very consistent very consistent for a
lot of folks who
who might dance with the wacky tobacci
on occasion so could you introduce this
in any way that makes sense to you just
in terms of of how sleep relates to food
intake relates to weight gain sleep and
food timing all of that jazz because
the endocannabinoids or changes in
endocannabinoids caused by Sleep loss
seem to increase hunger food intake on
thus weight gain it makes me wonder like
why would that be the case
why is that I have observed as someone
who's had a lot of sleep trouble that I
become ravenous or at least much more
compelled to overeat when I don't sleep
it's striking and I've certainly noticed
that too when I sort of travel if I'm
you know going back home to the UK to
England and my sleep is usually always
rough with that I definitely noticed the
change in my appetite and the evidence
is really very strong now that when
sleep gets short unfortunately it will
lead to a waistline that can expand
and the the early evidence came on to at
obesity Diplomat it's a very nice word
yeah exactly and my Twitter handle is
changing five minutes here and then at
some point there will just simply be
hashtag cancel called just leave
Diplomat which is kind of yeah but
anyway so the the early evidence looked
it it takes a village Internet it's
making streams come true all right sorry
go ahead the world will be a better
place without me I'm sure so uh two
appetite regulating hormones one was
called leptin one was called ghrelin and
leptin by the way is a hormone that says
to your brain okay don't eat it we think
of it almost like the satiety signal
that makes you when you've had food it
makes you feel Satisfied by your food
and so you don't want to eat more and
then growlin on the other hand it does
the opposite it is the I want to eat
more hormone it increases your appetite
ghrelin G stands for go eat the cookies
yeah exactly sort of G for my stomach is
growling and I desperately want to eat
more
and what they found was that when you
limit people to let's say just four to
five hours of sleep a night for several
nights
you see a dastardly change in those two
appetite hormones firstly what they
found was that lectin the don't eat the
I'm sort of satisfied with my meals tidy
signal that dropped by about 18 percent
if that wasn't bad enough levels of
ghrelin which is the hunger hormone that
increased by 28 so in some ways it's
almost like physiological Double
Jeopardy that you're getting punished
twice for the same crime of not sleeping
once by a loss of the signal that says
don't eat you're full with your food you
lose that signal and then if that wasn't
bad enough you ramp up your ghrelin
signal which is I'm hungry hunger levels
would increase by around about 24 to 25
percent depending on the study
so that was sort of the emerging
evidence on the appetite regulating
hormones and by the way that doesn't
necessarily lead to a consistent change
in eating more of every type of food the
unfortunate thing is that the class of
food that you start to increase your
greatest desire it's not just that you
want to eat more it's the things that
you want to eat more of are the things
that are more obesogenic so these are
more carbohydrate-rich Foods simple
sugary Foods ice cream sort of sweets
Etc and also they found an increase in
your preference for eating salty snacks
which can put you towards a path of
Greater hypertension so
so that was the evidence of the basic
appetite regulating hormone level but
then the more recent data came out
you're right that all of us even if
we're not smoking the
the wacky tobacco as you described all
of us have our own cannabinoids that we
release inside of our brain and our
bodies we have naturally occurring
cannabinoids in our brain and they're
called the endocannabinoids meaning that
they come from inside of us endo
and you're absolutely right that when
you give people exogenous cannabinoids
like THC it makes them hungry you get
the munchies but what they found was
that when you sleep deprived individuals
this has got nothing to do with THC or
cannabis or smoking weed you increased
the amount of these cannabinoids within
the the brain and within individuals and
so all of a sudden
you start to see perhaps it's not just
these leptin and ghrelin that are
changing to conspire to increase your
hunger in your waistline but it's also
that these endocannabinoids are
increasing and you can then start to ask
well you know why what why would that be
the case how can we explain those things
currently we we don't quite know one
hypothesis is that
the only time when you see
other species deprive themselves of
sleep because human beings in truth are
probably the only species that will
deliberately provide themselves of sleep
for no apparent good reason but animals
will do it occasionally and the most
common occurrence is when they're under
conditions of starvation
and so here under those conditions the
brain releases awake promoting chemical
called erection and the reason is
because the brain has figured out I'm
under conditions of starvation it must
mean that my ability to forage for food
in my standard perimeter during the time
that I'm awake is not yielding enough
food so I need to push myself to be
awake longer to forage in a wider
perimeter and therefore to find and
solve this
sort of caloric deficit so one
possibility is that because you are
deprived of sleep you're sort of getting
this this signal of let me ramp up my
Hunger even more let me drive up my
motivation to go and search for food
because otherwise I'm going to be in a
mission-critical kind of break glass in
case of emergency situation but we don't
truly understand why these these
hormonal patterns go awry we certainly
know that you will increase your intake
of food
we then want on to discover that it's
not just about what changes in your
endocannabinoids or in your hormones
because in fact choices that you make
for your foods are controlled by your
brain that's the central dominating
decision pivot point for here so we took
a group of individuals and we deprive
them of sleep and then we gave them a
full night of sleep and it was a
counterbalance study where they both go
through both full sleep and without
sleep and the next day we place them
inside an MRI scanner
and we started to show them different
images of food that range from really
unhealthy Foods
sort of like pizza and donuts and ice
cream all the way up to really healthy
different types of foods and they had to
rate the desire that they had for those
individual foods and we also did
something a little bit dastardly to make
it more ecologically valid we told them
and we did do this that one of those
items that they said that they found
desirable we would then serve them when
they came out of the MRI scanner and
they had to politely please eat that
food so it should just forced them to
make sure that they're making the
choices correctly not what we found is
that the brain you started to rate these
obesogenic Foods as much more desirable
and the reason was that the control
regions of the brain once again in the
prefrontal cortex was shut down whereas
more hedonic Drive centers within the
brain dopaminergic centers and also the
amygdala which is also controlling
hedonic food desires those ramped up in
terms of their activity and that's a
profile that we typically see in
patients who are suffering from obesity
it's this profile of what we would call
a brain state of hedonic eating that you
shift over into just going after
desirous Foods unhealthy Foods so it was
a two-part equation changes downstairs
in the body and then changes upstairs
within the brain
there have been since some cities
looking at dieting without sleep which I
think is probably some really
fascinating data but let me just pause
there for a second because I keep just
talking so
erection is that o-r-e-x-i-n how do you
spell
yes erection yep I was hoping you would
say e-r-e-x-i-n because then I was going
to suggest that you could actually
cross-sell the erection for male
Vitality after The Da Vinci Code magic
sleep device
you know I'll take my customers
television is assured after this
conversation I'll take my customary 15
it's fine
oh so erection I was asking about that
and also just contextualizing my own
mind everything you just said because
I'd love to get your read on just a
amateurs
play hypothesis and this is based this
came about after
unfortunately my personal experience of
many sleepless nights lots of sleep
deficit over many many decades and have
observed this eating
this increased volume of intake even if
it's healthier foods right if I'm trying
to exert control I'm still just eating a
lot more and the drive is so strong
that I started to wonder what the
evolutionary explanation for that might
be right if the let's say this is an
Adaptive and not a pathological Behavior
like what would how would this be
adaptive and I was thinking and this may
not hold any water but I was thinking if
you rob the body
of its ability to repair itself during
sleep
could this not be a compensatory
mechanism by which you try to fix things
by say driving up anabolism it's like
okay you're not going to give us the
sleep that we need fine we're going to
try to turn on all the anabolic
Machinery we can by throwing insulin
into hyperdrive by increasing caloric
intake which might have some effect on
testosterone or who knows what
do you think there might be anything
there or is that just me
yelling nonsense into the wind as usual
I think it's certainly one alternative
hypothesis
that what you're trying to do is
eat yourself in an overcoming way and
sort of to overcome the sleep
deprivation and see if you can placate
some of what you're not getting by way
of sleep I think that's one hypothesis
right now I think the evidence is
entertained in the other direction which
is sort of flipping the causal inference
which is that it's the lack of sleep
that your brain is receiving the signal
of which then suggests oh my goodness I
must be under conditions of starvation
because from an evolutionary standpoint
the only time that mother nature
ingrained in its biology has experienced
insufficient sleep is under conditions
of starvation and that's why you
increase the drive to eat other people
have suggested it's because of energy
expenditure but that has been largely
dismissed that's a myth which is that
when you are awake surely you are
burning many more calories than when
you're asleep and so the increase in
food intake is simply try trying to
offset the increased metabolic caloric
expenditure the problem is twofold
first that sleep itself metabolically is
an incredibly active process we think of
it as a passive process but
metabolically it's hugely demanding and
in fact the difference between you lying
on a couch doing nothing versus you
sleeping is a very small amount meaning
that sleep is a highly metabolic process
second if you look at it across a full
eight hour period of sleep if you keep
people awake in particular Chambers
where we can measure very concretely the
amount of caloric and metabolic activity
that's going on and how much how many
calories you're burning
what you find is that you will probably
burn only around about an extra 140
calories by being sleep deprived all
night than you would be if you slept
however the amount of increased calories
that you take on board is usually at
least double or triple that you will
overeat by somewhere in the region of
three to six hundred calories when you
are sleep deprived so it's not simply
that you are trying to amateur amateurs
oh my God these guys should see my diet
log 300 calories yeah maybe it's not
twofold maybe it's 10 for the 10x
situation and so right now that's the
sort of the model that we have which is
it it's not you trying to overcome
necessarily your caloric expenditure
because you do that plus a lot more and
that's why it sets you on a path towards
obesity and increased weight gain again
just
looking at this as a lay person who's
had a lot of sleep problems I I would
totally agree with the caloric deficit
if any being
I don't know it just seems trivial
enough that it wouldn't drive that type
of
overeating the reason I wonder about the
plausibility of turning on the anabolic
Machinery to try to
try to achieve repair that wasn't
permitted by insufficient sleep
is because when I think about and
yeah thank you for putting up with me
because I know that I'm coming at this
as a layperson who should know better
but I've done a lot of fasting done tons
of fasting up to 10 days right I've done
a lot of fasting and that's water
fasting
and so when I when I hear the example
which I believe which is the only time
you see animals depriving themselves of
sleep is when they are in under
starvation conditions or in
under conditions of food scarcity
it would seem to me that maybe another
way to put that would be
the only time that animals sleep very
little is when they're under those
conditions because they're not actively
I would imagine they're not actively
trying to deprive themselves of sleep
and the only reason I say that is that
it would seem to me based on my
experiences fasting if if I were to
extend that to then other mammals at
least or some other mammals
when you fast it gets really hard to
sleep it does very often at least I mean
you can experience tachycardia you can
have all sorts of I don't know if it's a
cholinergic response you could probably
tell me but it is very hard for a lot of
folks to
sleep when they fast and you take say
humans as an example right so if you
were really fast
you would
have trouble after after a handful of
days of course and some people would get
kidney pain or pain associated with
muscle loss because of the catabolism
now there are a couple ways that you can
attenuate that like one
is and it doesn't solve it completely
but helps a lot is to consume
supplemental electrolytes
and so one is to consume supplemental
electrolytes
another is to consume stuff that monkeys
like so much and that is fruit right so
fructose will help you to maintain blood
pressure where it might otherwise
plummet and you could get
what's it called orthostatic hypotension
where you stand up and you think you're
going to pass out and which which can
happen intolerance orthostatic
intolerance there we go
so so I just wonder
if the
lack of sleep is basically directly
caused by the caloric insufficiency
I think that was a bit of a word salad
that I just tossed all over the place no
let me sort of mix it further I think
it's a it's a delicious salad because
that evidence is Fairly reliable when
you speak to people who are fasting very
consistently they'll say one of the
things that's perhaps hardest about the
fast is not necessarily you know the
struggle with with Hunger it's also that
my sleep just takes a nosedive like a
dart into the ground
and if you look at the studies there is
there are some conflicting studies but
some cities are found firstly if you put
people on
either daytime fasting or reduce
calories and what we're talking about
here is as little as sort of 300
calories or less when you measure
changes in sleep regulating components
things like melatonin melatonin is a
hormone that helps time your sleep
when you do a reduced caloric diet there
is about a 20 impairment in melatonin
which is then associated with a
difficulty in falling asleep
although there are some studies I should
know by the way that with fasting even
though you struggle to fall asleep once
you fall asleep there may be less time
spent awake when you do finally get to
initiate sleep and so I think there's
Nuance there that I want to respect
probably the other evidence and there's
just not good enough evidence yet to
really look at this but
I think the strongest most
robust evidence is probably in areas of
religious based fasting such as Ramadan
where people will Fast from sunrise to
sunset for about a month and there what
we've noticed is probably at least five
specific changes first once again coming
back to orexin rather erects and oh
wrexin the the awake promoting chemical
by the way we discovered our accent by
way of cities in narcolepsy were
patients who have narcolepsy who have an
unstable wake sleep switch where they
just can't maintain wakefulness during
the day they keep flip-flopping back and
forth between unstable wake and sleep
what we discovered is that narcolepsy is
principally a condition of a deficiency
in erection in other words erection is
this wake promoting chemical and the
amount of erection that they release in
narcoleptic patients and the cells that
release it are markedly deficient and
the number of erection receptors in the
brain are deficient which we think
explains the reason why they lose the
Wake promoting on switch during the day
and why they are so susceptible to sleep
attacks but anyway I digress coming back
to Ramadan you see
individuals they the levels of erection
increase they have a decreased level of
peak melatonin as I sort of just
mentioned with reduced caloric diets
also the arrival of when that Peak and
melatonin occurs is much later into the
night in other words you're not getting
the signal of its Darkness it's night
time at the same time of your normal
bedtime you get it several hours later
which may in part explain why it's
harder for you to fall asleep
related their bedtimes drift forward
which is really interesting and we think
it's related to that delay in melatonin
release
Total Sleep Time decreases by
probably about an hour if you look at
those studies and we also see an
interesting dissociation sleep stages in
in Ramadan the thing that takes the
greatest hit seems to be rapid eye
movement sleep whereas non-rem sleep
seems to be largely unaffected
so right now that's probably some of the
best evidence that we have as to what's
going on to explain why people suffer
such problematic sleep when they're
going through fasting but again I think
most of these
looking at real true fasting are
required because those aren't
necessarily reflective of the fasting
that you're talking about
so let me make a few comments and then
I'll ask a thousand more questions so
the first I would say not to make light
of narcolepsy but if anyone listening
has not seen video of the fainting goats
which have been bred to have narcolepsy
that's actually not narcolepsy what is
that it looks very much like narcolepsy
but it's a condition where in patients
with who have narcolepsy one of the
other features is not just that you're
unstable in terms of your sleep wake and
you fall asleep during the day there's
something
called cataplexy and cataplexy happens
where all of a sudden if you get strong
emotion or you frighten
a patient with narcolepsy or an animal
with narcolepsy and there are dogs that
have been bred with the narcoleptic Gene
then all of a sudden they lose all
muscle tone and part of the reason is
when we go into REM sleep
we actually become paralyzed our brain
paralyzes our body so the mind can dream
safely but that same mechanism of
paralysis seems to go awry in narcolepsy
and these patients will go into this
just cataplectic attack where they all
lose all muscle tone and they'll
collapse down on the floor and it looks
like they've gone into REM sleep they
haven't they're awake they're just
locked into the unusual paralysis that
would normally happen during REM sleep
whereas with the fainting goats it's
actually a different mechanism where
when they get frightened all of a sudden
their muscles become incredibly rigid
and then they topple over yeah they look
like some type of statue you would see
in a menagerie for a Christmas display
in front of a church or something I mean
they've totally just stiffened and then
fall right away that's right yeah and
they will sometimes just hop on their
straight legs to try and get away or
they just Keel over but that's important
things but you can go online and look at
sort of search for dogs and narcolepsy
and you'll see many of these things it's
a stunning condition and very tragic of
course for The Knockout patients
cataplexy is a major daytime disruptive
feature all right so glad I brought up
fainting goats just so I can stand
corrected so would it be fair to say
that these are cataplectic cataplexic
goats or what would you call them
no not on the basis of the way that we
term cataplexy within Knox oh right
because that would be the loss of muscle
tone correct exactly what would you even
call them if you wanted to use a fancy
scientific term my typical term is just
muscle rigidity that they go into a
muscle spasm rigidity and that all of a
sudden it's that they had red this genes
and I think there's some evidence that
because it's bread there was this whole
group of I think it was cattle actually
that had this genetic abnormality what
was interesting is that the cattle were
housed next to a train track right at
the point where the train was on its
points and it would always have to honk
its horn until reliably no the whole
heard and you knew it because you knew
the timing of the train it would come
through you knew that the train would
honk its horn it would startle the
cattle and the whole field of cattle
would just collapse on man but anyway so
I'm sorry scientific tension oh no I
mean I love science but we don't have to
do it all the time all right
well let's let's get to Story Time with
Tim related to the Olympics for a second
and then we're gonna get to a question
about modafinil so I'm going to seed
that there was a time I want to say this
is maybe two or three Olympics ago could
have been further back where lo and
behold something amazing was observed
and that was almost all of the sprinters
who made it to the final rounds of the
Olympics
were
prescribed modafinil because they had
been diagnosed as narcoleptics by their
doctors so who knew all of these
world-class sprinters would happen to be
narcoleptics it's amazing what a
coincidence what a coincidence so the
subtext here is that modafinil can be
used as a performance enhancing drug now
modafinil as I understand it I think
that is
provigil and not new vigil maybe it's
both provincial yeah provigil do we know
how modafinil Works do we understand how
it works or was that a discovery
in search of a mechanism in a sense
because there's so many drugs that are
used including some very common drugs
where we don't really know exactly how
they do what they do we just know that
they do X is modafinil understood well
no it's not okay it certainly doesn't
work by the classic so we used to
prescribe we science community and
clinical we used to prescribe patients
with narcolepsy amphetamines to try and
brute force them awake so they didn't
have that daytime that excessive daytime
sleepiness that is so prohibitive of a
normal functioning life and now that
clinical practice has shifted towards
prescribing modafinil modafinil like
amphetamine is a wake promoting chemical
of course but it doesn't seem to work by
way of that classic
amphetamine based root exactly how it
works it's a little bit unclear it may
be working by way of stimulating levels
of noradrenaline Serotonin and perhaps
also levels of another chemical called
histamine which is a very strong like
promoting chemical
histamine which we make right do we
speak about just quick side note for
people who have ever felt drowsy after
taking a Benadryl that's right would be
experiencing an antihistamine yeah
that's how we discovered part of the the
role of of histamine as a wake and a
sleep regulating chemical was that the
older forms of anti-allergy medications
that they would cross the blood-brain
barrier and the anti-allergy medications
were principally blocking this thing
called histamine because in the body it
controls the allergic response but if it
gets into the brain then it also
decreases levels of histamine in the
brain and histamine is a weak promoting
chemical so when you decrease it you
result in a level of sleepiness and it
starts to knock you out so those are
some of the different current chemical
systems that we think modafinil may be
working on but it's still very unclear
right now yeah when I'm asking this
partially as a public service because I
know
of a lot of folks out there who are
self-described biohackers who use
modafinil
long term without cycling off and I just
strikes me as a bad idea
when the mechanisms are poorly
understood
but who am I who am I to say I will I
will say from personal experience
because I've experimented with the
national
I have never in my life
experienced the development of tolerance
as quickly with anything
than with modafinil I mean it is it is
remarkable I will say if I use it once
at the sort of therapeutic dosing range
amazing day super productive oh my God I
just got a week's worth of productivity
crammed into one day the next day same
dose doesn't work the tolerance that I
develop and the necessity to increase
the dose is so
violently rapid that I decided very
quickly I didn't want to use this stuff
because
I also experienced and this should this
will not be a surprise to you that if I
used it for a few days and I'd already
developed a tolerance by that point and
I stopped my productivity was absolutely
annihilated for multiple days I just
didn't didn't find it to be the tool for
me
so that's that's part of the reason I
was asking about modafinils just in case
people out there are using it yeah I
think I would be concerned about its
long-term use in part because of its
disruptive impact on sleep and also the
fact that in biology it's very rare that
you get a free lunch and when you fight
biology you normally lose and the way
you know you've lost is long-term
disease and sickness yep I did find that
my my immune system felt funny also when
I was when I was using modafinil after a
while
yeah I it didn't it didn't sit super
well with me but that's not to malign it
as a tool in the toolkit right
especially for people who need it let's
talk about the name that has been
invoked several times and we may do it
by speaking more broadly about sleep
drugs The Good the Bad and the Ugly but
let's have it also include trazodone
since it's come up now at least twice
how would you suggest people think about
sleep medications and sleep architecture
where should we begin
yeah you know it's it's really difficult
again just to stay for the record I'm
not a medical doctor and so this isn't
anything sort of medical and I've always
been reticent to sort of go on record I
suppose because of that because I it's
not clinical advice but I can at least
try to offer some of the scientific
evidence regarding classic sleeping
pills and then maybe more about the more
novel compounds that you and I have
discussed
right now I'm probably not a big
advocate of the classic sleeping pills
or even the newer classic sleeping pills
and it don't necessarily need to name
any names everyone can name them but
they're in a class of drugs that we call
the sedative hypnotics and the problem
is that sedation is not sleep and so the
way that those drugs work those classic
sleeping pills is that they go after a
chemical system in the brain that's an
inhibitory system it's called the Gaba
system which stands for gamma
aminobutyric acid which is the major
kind of red light stop signal in the
brain
so when you take those sleeping pills
I'm certainly not going to argue that
you're awake at night you're not but to
argue that you're in naturalistic sleep
I think is perhaps an equal fallacy
because if I were to show you the
electrical signature of your sleep with
and without those classic sleeping pills
they're not the same thing
and one of the potential concerns is
that if you map out the electrical
brainwave sort of signature of sleep the
spectrum of electrical brainwave
activity you and I were discussing deep
sleep and it's particularly the deepest
of the deep slow brain waves and we can
come on to some of the functions of
those for learning and memory and immune
function but were those classic sleeping
pills will leave the most significant
dent in the quality of your sleep is
particularly in the deepest of that deep
sleep brainwave activity so it's taking
a bite out of that
so
that would perhaps be scientific cause
for being mindful about them now by the
way current Medical Practice suggests
that there is a time and a place for
those sleeping pills but they are
typically not advocated long term and
again please speak to your doctor don't
do anything on the basis of my advice
I would say though that one of the other
aspects of those sleeping medications
is first that you typically develop
tolerance you also get some pretty
unfortunate side effects
things like next day drowsiness drowsy
driving related accidents and increased
risk of dementia has also been evidence
that it increases your risk for Falls
leading to hip fracture and skull
fracture there's an FDA warning about
these sleep medications recently that
was published for those concerns
and due to that I think back in
2016 the American College of Physicians
offered the recommendation that sleeping
pills should not be the first line
treatment for insomnia it should be
something called cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia so I think they've
Fallen somewhat out of favor if you were
to come back to what I was telling you
that they don't leave you with the very
best quality of electrical sleep
they certainly will increase classically
the amount of sleep that you have and
even in fact they can look like they
increase the amount of deep sleep that
you get on the basis of classical sleep
scoring but if we separate the brainwave
activity then you start to see that the
news is not all good but if you're
sleeping longer shouldn't you get at
least some benefit of that and the
reason I became less bullish two on
those medications was because there's a
great study done by a colleague of mine
Marcus Frank and he was dosing animals
with different sleep medications and
firstly he was using a learning Paradigm
and as the animals would learn they
would create this memory Trace in the
brain that he would map and he could
measure the strength of the synaptic
connections within the brain
then what would happen is that if you
let those animals sleep naturally the
next day they would come back and the
strength of that memory trace the
strength of those synaptic connections
had been increased even more and this is
part of the reason why sleep is so
beneficial for learning and memory
what he then did was dose those animals
with classic sleeping pills one of which
was Zolpidem or Ambien
and firstly those animals certainly they
did sleep longer which you would think
on the basis of then sleep's role in
learning in memory and plasticity would
mean that the memory Trace was even
stronger the next day
however what he found was that not only
was the memory trace the memory circuit
not strengthened by way of that sleeping
pill induced sleep it was actually
reduced in fact he found almost a 50
reduction a weakening in the strength of
the memory trait as a consequence so I
think as I said there's a time and a
place that clinical medicine believes
there is a significant use case for
these sleeping medications but I think
in the long term the evidence is
favoring against them and going towards
psychological treatments or other types
of non-traditional sleep medications
things like as you mentioned trazodone
you can also speak about pregabalin and
Gabapentin let's get after it why don't
we keep the momentum so which would you
like to put on the platter first
trazodone I think probably trazodone
yeah right now trazodone is probably the
most off-label prescribed sleep
medication it's not currently it doesn't
receive the current
sort of labeling for a sleep medication
but it is used by many doctors off label
trazodone I find fascinating for a
number of reasons
it's originally designed as an
anti-anxiety or antidepressant
medication in in higher doses but what
we've discovered is that in lower Doses
and lower doses being anywhere between
25 milligrams all the way up to maybe
300 milligrams it's quite sleep inducing
and the reason I find it interesting
is firstly it does not work like classic
sleeping pills which as I said just
knock out the cortex sedate the cortex
by stimulating the inhibitory
transmitter Gaba instead trazodone
actually works on the three
neurochemical systems that we've
mentioned before which are the Wake
promoting systems within the brain
specifically trazodone will Target the
noradrenaline system within the brain
and it's what we call an alpha-1
adrenergic antagonist which simply means
that it dials down the volume on
neurodrenaline it is a 5ht2a antagonist
meaning it reduces serotonin activity
and finally it reduces down histamine by
targeting the H1 receptor which again we
spoke about histamine being wake
promoting if you block it with
anti-allergy medications you get sleepy
so trazodone has either trazodone I know
sounds quite scary it sounds like a
tranquilizer and it's not like that at
all it's actually very nuanced what I
like about its profile perhaps is that
from a scientific perspective is that it
tries to do something more naturalistic
it tries to switch off the volume of the
Wake promoting regions and therefore
allows sleep the passage of sleep too
be produced and arrive with you in a
more naturalistic way
also one of the other interesting
features is that not only does it and by
the way it seems to be quite effective
there was a meta-analysis that was done
recently on 11 different really
well-controlled randomized
placebo-controlled trials or rcts across
probably almost around 500 different
patients
what they found probably was three
things of interest the first is dose
then age and then duration of use or
efficacy they found that regardless of
the dose whether it be below 50
milligrams or above 50 milligrams it
provided benefits for reducing the time
it takes to fall asleep which is what
you were describing with trazodone use
it reduces the amount of time you then
are spending awake for the rest of the
night it increased deep non-rem sleep
but here was the fascinating part for me
didn't come at the cost of REM sleep
which in some ways is a little bit
surprising they're not utterly
antagonistic in their role RAM and
non-rem but I mentioned earlier on in
the conversation that you can increase
deep non-rem sleep by way of exercise
but if you look at some of those studies
when you increase deep non-rem you can
have an exercise induced reduction in
REM sleep
but yet what's interesting about
trazodone is that it seems to increase
the amount of deep non-rem sleep but
leaves REM sleep untouched REM you don't
get a consequence to REM sleep we don't
quite understand why that is but that's
one of the nice things is that whether
it be below 50 milligrams or above 50
milligrams you get these benefits the
age dependency is quite nice because if
you look at people who are younger than
60 years old you get these sleep
benefits but even you see many not all
of them but many of the Sleep same sleep
benefits for people who are 60 years or
older
and we know that as we get older as you
and I discussed earlier the harder that
sleep becomes and so that could arguably
be a more challenging use case where
that medication would fail yet you seem
to get quite a lot of the distance and
the benefit even as you get older so I
think that's a potential upside
and then the other aspect of it was the
duration of action they did look at this
which comes on to aspects of Tolerance
and withdrawal
that didn't necessarily seem to be a
significant tolerance buildup where you
if you look at acute dosing for one week
you get these nice benefits but then if
you keep assessing people week after
week up to one month at least in the
meta-analysis the benefits were still
there for the most part would suggest
that there isn't necessarily tolerance
to the drug that those benefits persist
even when you continue to take the drug
so right now that's why I think it's a
it's an interesting drug in terms of its
profile and how it works so I'm not
anti-medication please don't think that
it's just that if those medications
aren't producing naturalistic sleep I
prefer to say so but here it seems to be
a very different mechanism
now to those listening they might say
well wait a minute
Dr Walker you have said there is no
biological free lunch this sounds like a
free lunch so if you were to take the
other Podium right so you're on the
debate team and you you want to make the
counter case
what is the downside risk or what is the
be careful when you use Trazodone
argument to be mid
I think right now if I wanted to steal
man the argument on the other side I
would say it's unclear what the long
term necessarily Health Associated risks
are
certainly trazodone is being used for
decades as I said for anti depressant
purposes and anti-anxiety purposes and
it seems to have a largely safe profile
so maybe I'm less concerned about that
but what I would still like to see are
the studies that look at things like
learning memory plasticity for your
brain because
things like classic sleeping pills like
mbn have been found to produce
non-naturalistic sleep those obvious to
these have them been done and found that
the functional benefits of sleep are not
emergent when you are taking those drugs
and that raised the red flag even more
so I don't think we have those studies
yet for things like trazodone not at
least in a very strict specific way so
for me I think I would still want to
Warrant caution and look at those
outcome measures long term
agreed totally agreed yeah
I mean certainly for a
learning fanatic
learning obsessive purpose and like
myself those are highly important
questions that lead me at least for the
time being to
not a doctor I don't play one on the
internet folks but to to cycle right
with medical supervision but to try to
not always hit the same nail with the
same Hammer each each night and I'm not
giving medical advice that's just my
personal approach
question on the serotonin type 2A
antagonism how strong is that effect and
part of the reason that I ask is I know
there are other
drugs well-known drugs cancer in I'm
saying that correctly which is
classified as an anti-hypertensive by
The Who and the NIH is being
investigated by some as a potential and
I have a lot of strong opinions about
this that I'll save for another time but
for a potential trip canceling
intervention so if someone is having
a psychedelic experience that has become
unmanageable or unpleasant and I I would
actually
generally take the position that I think
it is
premature to just hit the Escape shoot
in a lot of those
in in those cases unless we're looking
at actual physical risk
which you know the the lead up is very
important but let's just say there are
companies for-profit companies who are
looking at cancer and as a potential
trip stopper and I'm wondering if
trazodone would be strong enough to
exert that kind of effect I just don't
know at what type of dose it would even
be plausible not to say that I'm going
to use it for that purpose but I'm
wondering
if it could go sort of Toe to Toe with
some of these other type 2A antagonists
I think it's a good question I don't
think we really know what percentage
strength of pushback on each one of
those three neuro chemical systems
trazodone exerts its principle effect is
it more so a histamine so if you rank
order how it's impacting nor adrenaline
serotonin and histamine is it that it's
principally histamine where you get the
greatest let's say you know 70 of the
impact is on histamine then 20 percent
is on noradrenaline and then 10 is on
serotonin or Is It reversed in that
order we don't know I think once you
know that you would then be able to
understand exactly
how the utility value of it for pulling
the rip cord as you described to exit
the trip one way you could do that is in
animal studies where you were to dose
animals with trazodone and then you
could selectively block each one of
those things so I could give trazodone I
could selectively block noradrenaline
receptors and leave serotonin and
histamine unchanged and ask what's the
impact and then I can go through those I
can leave noradrenaline and histamine
unchanged and block serotonin and then
leave noradrenaline and serotonin
unchanged and block histamine and that
way I could create this rank ordering
effect of the impact of trazodone on
each of those three systems I at least
don't know of evidence that has
systematically done that to disentangle
the priority rating of those three
things
got it and I should issue a warning here
which is
work with professionals before you start
combining drugs or taking any drugs for
that matter because
if you don't read the fine print on what
I'm saying you can get yourself into
trouble so
to give an example there are some cases
where ssris will decrease the
hallucinogenic effects psychedelic
effects of given compounds there are
other cases
most maybe not most notably but notably
in the case of Ayahuasca where if you
combine psychiatric medications with
Ayahuasca you could actually suffer from
potentially highly dangerous serotonin
syndrome
and so instead of reducing the effect
you would be compounding the effects of
The Experience so you got to be very
very careful with the stuff you can get
yourself into deep water very quickly
and get yourself into trouble so I think
that's actually a really important point
which is the interactive what we call
polypharmacy yeah a more benign version
of that or perhaps a less malignant is a
better way of describing it version of
that actually comes on to back to our
discussion of caffeine there is some
emerging evidence that using ssris
increases your sensitivity to caffeine
and it decreases the clearance of
caffeine and so you can think well I'm
this type of person with my caffeine use
and then you can start taking these
ssris
which then all of a sudden you realize
I'm not sleeping as well as I used to
and I don't think it's because of the
caffeine intake it's because my caffeine
intake has remain stable I haven't
changed that but what's changed is the
interaction between those ssris ramping
up the duration the severity of action
of caffeine so you have to be really
thoughtful and that's where it gets very
complex that's where us human beings are
desperately messy things so messy wow
what the what a tangled web we weave
what a sad situation would be if someone
were using trazodone for sleep and yet
experience this
dramatic magnification of their
experience with caffeine and netted out
in the red that would be a real bummer
yeah we don't yet know if it's trusted
in particular these were the sort of the
more classic ssris so right now jury is
out yeah trazodone's pretty weak yeah I
don't want to call it a failed
antidepressant but it's like by the time
it starts a first line yeah treatment
and that's why it's become its most
popular use right now is not people just
fall asleep antidepressant it's because
it's yeah sleeping juicy yep
all right so let's let's LeapFrog to
pregabalin
and Gabapentin you can you can take
either
Gabapentin people may recognize because
veterinarians love to hand it out like
Pez candy when when you take your dog in
or your cat in but yeah which of those
would you like to talk about first
I mean we can talk about both of them
because in some ways they have yeah the
pot of the same class of sort of drugs
perfect pregabalin and Gabapentin
you're right that they're used in for
multiple different
reasons one of which is pain medication
muscle relaxant
neurologically they are often used in
seizure disorders because they will
reduce down the seizure tendency
and you would think by the names
pregabalin and Gabapentin that they're
going to act by way of targeting once
again the Gaba system that inhibitory
system and so the sedatives and so you
are don't seem to be a big fan of those
Matt
but it turns out that's not the case it
shouldn't be fooled they actually impact
the functioning of calcium channels on
neurons and the those calcium channels
will dictate the firing of those neurons
and so you can reduce down the firing
propensity of those neurons that's why
they're given in seizure disorders in
epilepsy to try to suppress the
excessive this hyperpolarization this
hyperactivity of the brain that creates
the epicenter of the seizure if you look
at the evidence it's interesting when
you dose both naive individuals and
meaning naive patients who have never
received either of these drugs or don't
have seizure disorders or sleep
disorders
it does they both do seem to increase
the amount of deep non-rem sleep and
they do seem to reduce the amount of
light stage one non-rem sleep
so I think they are interesting I think
there's probably indirect mechanisms too
they certainly have a relaxing property
they can be a muscle relaxant
they can reduce some degree of anxiety
we know also know that those drugs will
decrease down both the flight or flight
branch of the nervous system and what's
called the HBA axis the stress-related
cortisol axis so I think part of it is
because they reduce down anxiety which
as we've described before is not great
for sleep so it's an indirect mechanism
and then the other component is that it
may actually have some unknown to us
right now neuronal impacts by way of
calcium channel alteration that
increases deep sleep but right now I
don't know of anyone who's pulled apart
that mechanism within the brain itself
question on pregabalin so when I first
used pregabalin so I had been using
trazodone as monotherapy and then
introduced pregabalin
I experienced
and it was
very noticeable could just be placebo
effect but I wasn't anticipating it
which is why
unless I'm just seeing things
it wasn't sort of expectancy effect
because I wasn't looking for it but I
seem to notice
a carryover effect
of lowered anxiety so an anxiolytic
effect all the way through maybe the
first five six hours of my waking
subsequent day after using pregabalin
pre-bed is that
a mirage or is there a plausible
explanation for that
no I think there is a political
explanation I mean it actually has quite
a
well not quite short but a somewhat
short half-life of about five to six
hours so when you come back then to the
quarter life we're talking about
somewhere around 12 hours so it would
make sense that it's in the first part
of the day where you still get that sort
of floaty
reduced jittery feeling in the morning
where things just feel a little bit more
relaxed because that still is present in
your system it depends on the dose
by the way pregabalin and Gabapentin in
the Sleep field are principally used not
for insomnia but actually to treat a
sleep disorder called restless leg
syndrome which is a horrific disorder
where you get these in America I think
you call them charlie horses but in
England will sort of just get these
creepy crawly feelings in your muscles
and you have to move you have to stretch
them it disrupts sleep terribly it's a
it's a pretty tough sleep disorder and
it's used there to try to treat some of
the aspects of the muscle cramps and the
muscle problems
there you can go up to doses I think
people can use up to 225 milligrams of
pregabalin Gabapentin maybe up to 600
milligrams
so there you can get lingering after
effects that are not only a reduced
level of anxiety but also an increase in
sleepiness that people kind of don't
like it that they have you know next
morning grogginess and hangover effect
so one has to be a little bit thoughtful
for dose I think but it makes complete
sense based on the half-life of what
you're describing there you'd still get
some of that benefit
so I do know someone I don't want to
name names here I'll protect protect the
guilty but
who is a
let's call this person a pharmacological
Champion they have high tolerance for
everything and
pregabalin force them to tap out they
they in the sense that they were so laid
out not laid up but altered the next day
they were like okay hmm that was too
much that was too much yeah
I do not have that experience personally
but I do find it
to be
a fascinating drug it really is a
fascinating drug and I don't want to
become too dependent on it I should take
a step back and also say lest people
think that I am just swallowing pills
all day to
wake up and then feel ex not feel why
and then go to sleep
what I find is that if I simply have
these drugs available and I put them on
my nightstand and say if I'm not asleep
in 20 minutes or 30 minutes I'm going to
give myself permission to take
some of these sleep aids that's enough a
lot of the time just knowing it's there
having a rule in place
often allows me to get to sleep without
anything
I think this is such a powerful message
thanks for bringing it up which is
you know it's almost this strange
placebo effect of knowing security is
there because when you suffer from
insomnia and I've been there too
one of the miserable Parts is that you
lose all faith in your ability to sleep
in other words 100 sleep controls you
you do not control your sleep
and by way of these types of medications
that's why I'm not completely
anti-medication I think there's enormous
value in you regaining your confidence
that every time I go into this thing
called my bedroom because when you're
insomnia if you never suffered from
insomnia you would never think this but
when you walk into the bedroom it's
already a trigger you already start to
get Negative emotions you look at the
bed and you think I know what's going to
happen I am going to have a miserable
night of sleep
and just to have a pharmacologically
assured
it's not guaranteed but certainly higher
probability of being able to get into
bed and fall asleep at that point you've
turned the tables now you control your
sleep rather than your sleep controls
you that freedom that release from the
incarceration of the
I think vicious condition of insomnia is
incredibly powerful and I'm so glad that
that's what you experience now it's it's
a miserable place to be it's a huge Boon
just to know that you have something
reliable that can Brute Force the
problem towards a solution if needed
yeah is not to suggest that I always
want to Brute Force the solution and you
and I have also spoken about this where
there are tools out there like cbti
right cognitive behavioral therapy
for insomnia that are
extremely valuable
but if your mind
has suddenly become on some level
or
is
I don't want to say the enemy but if the
mental self-talk is such that you walk
into the bedroom you try to sleep you're
failing to sleep you start berating
yourself you get angry then you start to
worry about what the next day is going
to look like
so now your heart rate is 30 faster your
cortisol is being released and on and on
it goes in this vicious cycle that
further ensures you are not going to
sleep you know knowing that you have
the emergency option which will put you
to sleep is a tremendous
stress reliever and I have found that
just having it there
just having the break glass in case of
emergency pills in the night stand allow
me oftentimes to sleep without taking
anything and it's just the security of
knowing it's there I'm so glad that's
the case for you know and I am also a
big advocate of cbti going to behavioral
therapy for insomnia
which is just as efficacious as classic
things like Ambien but I would also note
that it's
not uncommon that people combine both
cognitive behavioral therapy which is
the psychological treatment that people
can look up cbti together with these
types of sleep medications to produce
the very best benefits and then at some
point maybe you start to taper down the
pharmacology maintain the cognitive
behavioral therapy components and lead
people out into that pathway of
confidence with their sleep
but it's just having that reassurance
can make the world of difference and the
other aspect you know with pharmacology
and I know it maybe it goes against the
idea of no free lunches
sometimes in medicine and science we
think of taking medicines as putting us
out of balance and that's the mentality
that people have I think rightly so so
their resistance against pharmacology
sometimes they're a way that I think
about it is that whatever condition that
you're in that has led you to think
about pharmacology probably means that
you are biologically and physiologically
out of balance and what those
medications are doing is actually
putting you back into a more natural
biological balance rather than the
inverse view that perhaps some people
rightly have which is when I take these
drugs I'm putting myself into an
artificial unnatural imbalance that may
not necessarily be the case
that's a great observation and I think
this is also a pretty good place to
start Landing the plane and I don't know
if you'd be open to this so you can
listen to my ramblings for another two
and a half hours and put up with my
questions but would you would you be
open to doing a round two at some point
oh just sign me up all right beautiful
anytime I would love to so let me give
people if it's okay with you I'm gonna
give people a teaser of what we might
cover
this is a a non-exhaustive list but
there are a number of things that we
brainstorm beforehand I do not know the
answers to these things and I would
really love to explore them so we have
sleep learning memory and creativity and
there are many bullets to explore there
we have sleep and sex intercourse orgasm
masturbation libido all my favorite
things so we can talk about that next
time around in round two and then also
dreaming and lucid dreaming so I have a
long-standing multi-decade long interest
in lucid dreaming and I really want to
dig into dreaming of the steering so
those are just a few of the things that
we we can and should explore in a round
two Matt is there anything you would
like to mention
in closing that we haven't brought up
anything you would like to point people
to
certainly people will want to follow you
at dastardly Diplomat on Twitter I'm
kidding it's at sleep Diplomat
on Twitter but are there any resources
websites you'd like to point people to
closing comments recommendations
anything at all that you'd like to bring
up
no firstly I would just say I think I
love those topics I think there's so
much to discuss and maybe you know when
people are threading you and I in on
Twitter they can sort of chime in as to
whether those topics sound great and
anything else that we can discuss I
would love to do that
I think people have had enough of my
dulcet British tones I won't say too
much more if you want to find out more
about sleep I would probably say
the best place to to learn more about
what I'm doing with sleep is probably my
own podcast which
it took us months and months to come up
with the the creative naming of it and
it's called the Matt Walker podcast
and so you can just find that on all
places where you get your podcasts so
that's probably the Matt Walker podcast
is the probably the best place to get
more info on me
but no I will keep my mouth shut I've
said enough I've spilled enough of my
diatripe
to notable people with anything more
so British so British I love it
those dulcet tones uh some people have
suggested that my personality may be the
best prophylactic known to man
so I'm sure some people have probably
lost the will to live listening to me or
during this conversations well all the
better to bring your mellifluous Dorset
tones back for the conversation around
orgasms and masturbation next time
around yeah maybe finally I will sort of
redeem myself with all of this kind of
like bad news about different alcohol
and caffeine all of a sudden I can give
you some good news about what sex
masturbation and why you have your own
sleep fate in your hands literally when
it comes to masturbation so
oh my God what a cliffhanger so folks
stick around we have a lot of exciting
things coming and this has been a
fantastic conversation thank you so much
Matt for taking the time and also for
doing the work and the research and
designing these studies and not only
executing on the research but conveying
it then in a way that makes it
understandable and useful to a broader
audience a lot of science can stay in
the
the distinguished hallways of
universities and be read by peers in
journals but it takes a very separate
and valuable set of skills to be able to
translate that without dumbing it down
or sacrificing integrity
to communicate to a broader audience and
I think you do a tremendous job of that
so thank you very much really appreciate
it thank you
so much for that Tim I really appreciate
those words thank you absolutely and to
everybody listening we will have links
to everything in the show notes as per
usual at tim.blog podcast so until next
time be a little kinder than is
necessary to others and to yourself
have faith that if you have sleep issues
and I've had sleep issues some very very
crippling
sleep issues for decades that there is
hope there are tools and we will be and
have been discussing some of the options
that are worth investigating And
discussing with your licensed
professionals
and thank you so much for tuning in so
until next time take care everybody